ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TODAY'S TUESDAY OCTOBER TENTH.
WE ARE GOING TO START IS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE'LL START WITH.
DOCTOR CHOI IS IN THE ROOM A.
B..
I REMEMBER FIVE AB TWENTY TWO OH
NINE
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON THE
HAND THE MEMBERS.
.
AND.
HIGH ONE ARE NOT THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY OFFER
ME TWO PERCENT ARE MIGHT BE ALOT
AB TWENTY TWO. OR NINE.
THIS BILL LOT WOULD INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
A DATA BANK CAN ALLOW ON ACCOUNT
OF TO REMAIN.
SO CALLED IN DORMANT.
PRIOR TO THAT MEETING TO CLOSE
DOWN THE ACCOUNT AND THE
TRANSFER INTO.
OUR MONEY SO TO THE YEAR STATE
THAT TREASURER FROM THREE YEARS
TO FIVE YEARS.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE LENGTH OF TIME FROM
TWO TO THREE YEARS SELF FOR
WHICH.
NOW IF THE ACCOUNT THE
SUPPLEMENT THAT UP THAT THE BANK
MUST TO STOP THE SENDING OUT
NOTICES SUCKED IT UP
A BANK ACCOUNT HOLDER.
STATING THAT THE UNCLAIMED THE
PROPERTY ON MAY BE TRANSFERRED
THAT TO THE STATE THE.
IF FOR THEIR SON NO
COMMUNICATION WHAT ACTIVITY ON
THE WOMAN ACCOUNT.
THIS NOTICE A REQUIREMENT IS ARE
CURRENTLY IN.
STATE LAW.
CURRENTLY OUT MANY INDIVIDUAL
OUR BANK ACCOUNT HOLDER SO WHO
MAYBE YEAH UTILIZING THE
ACCOUNT.
AS A PURELY. ARE A SAVINGS
MAY NOT THEIR INTENT TO HAVE FOR
ANY ACTION.
OF BUT THE POSSIBLE WHAT WOULD
DROOL ON.
ONE OF SUCH AN ACCOUNT.
IN MANY CASES INDIVIDUAL SO.
OFF NOW OPEN THIS
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
AND THE CHOOSE.
NOT TO ACT ON THAT COUNT THE
FULL MANY YEARS.
IN ADDITION INDIVIDUAL OR SO WHO
TRAVEL ALL PHONE.
ALL FOR BUSINESS OR PERSONAL
REASONS.
NOW WHAT INDIVIDUALS SO WHO ARE
HOSPITALIZED THE FOR EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME MAY NOT BE YA
MAKING PERIODIC UP WOULD DRAW
WARS.
WHAT DEPOSITS SAW THIS THE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS?
THE LACK OF ACTIVITY OUT WITHIN
THIRTY YEARS SOME MAY NOT BE.
OUT DUE TO THE BANK ACCOUNT
ORDER NOT THE HAVING AN INTEREST
IN THE FUNDS.
THE SHORTER PERIOD DAHLE OF A
THREE YEAR SAVOV DORMANCY FORCES
ARE MANY BANKING INSTITUTIONS SO
TO SPEND A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
AND THE RESOURCES. ON A SENDING
OUT DON'T NOTICE IS UP TO THE
BANK ACCOUNT HOLDERS SO
HOPEFULLY TORMUND ACCOUNTS.
IF I AFTER THIS SO.
UP.
DESCRIBE THE NORSE PUREE NOTICED
PERIOD.
BUT THE BANK GOT DOES NOT THAT
RECEIVE UP RESPONSE OF FROM THE
BANK ACCOUNT HOLDER.
FUNDS.
AS CHEAP PUT THE STATE
TREASURER.
THIS IS ARE NOT ON NOT IDEAL
SITUATION FOR EITHER THE BANKING
INSTITUTION OR THE INDIVIDUAL
BANCO.
ACCOUNT HOLDER.
SINCE THE INDIVIDUAL LOT WOULD
BE REQUIRED THAT TO GO THROUGH A
TEDIOUS TO PROCESS TO RETRIEVE
THE FUNDS. ONES ARE THEY SG TOOK
OUR STATE.
FOR MANY INDIVIDUAL HOURS SO WHO
ARE STRUGGLING OUT WITH A
HEALTHY ISSUES SURFACES SAW ONE
ADDITIONAL LAYER AND DOM A
ROADBLOCK FOR THEM TO. RETRIEVE
THE MONIES ARE THAT. THEY ARE
OUTRIGHT FREEDIA NOTE THAT
BELONGS TO THEM.
AB TWENTY TWO OR NINE IS SOUGHT
A WIN WIN NOW FOR THE BANKING
INSTITUTIONS
BY ENABLING OF THIS BANG SET TO
RETAIN THE FUNDS TO FOR LONGER
PERIODS. AS WELL AS SOME FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL BANK ACCOUNT HOLDERS
WHO CAN REST ASSURED. THAT
THEY'LL FUNDS ARE ARE SECURE AND
THE MAINTAINED THAT IN THEIR
TOWN THE FOR THE LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME.
IN ADDITION PASSED THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAS A
STATED THE.
IT IS SO VIDEO GORDON TO REUNITE
THE PROPERTY OWNER WITH YET WE
UNCLAIMED THE PROPERTY.
BY LEAVING THE PROPERTY I IN THE
ACCOUNT OF THE ORIGINATION MANY
BANK ACCOUNT HOLDER SO IT WOULD
HAVE A MORE TIME TO ACCESS TO
VIDEO FUNDS.
MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT AWARE
OF TO STATES UP ON CLAIMED THE
PROPERTY PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE.
THANK YOU.
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HERE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOD FORGIVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
I WONDER IF FARM NOW FRANCES SO
QUARTER IS HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
SHE WASN'T PLAYING MUCH COME UP
HERE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
YEAH BUT SHE'S HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO ARE ONE NINE
AND A CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ALPHA LICENSE SO OUR
INVESTIGATORS SO GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU JIM WOOD REFLECTS.
THANK YOU OF CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I
GUESS I REPRESENT.
THE LARGEST INVESTIGATOR
ASSOCIATION IN THE WORLD
ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS.
AND SOME OF OUR MEMBERS TO HELP
PEOPLE.
WE COVER A STUDENT FUNDS.
BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
MY PERSONAL LIFE.
MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
AND TODAY EVEN THOUGH WE'VE GONE
THROUGH PROBATE. AND IT'S
COMPLETED I'M STILL FINDING.
FUNDS THAT ADMINISTRATIVE.
IT'S BEEN FIVE YEARS
SO I THINK FIVE YEARS IS THE
MINIMUM PERSONALLY A MATTER
TIME.
THAT ASHIDA PLANTS SHOULD BE
HELD BY THE STATE.
AND BESIDES THE MEMBERS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR ASSOCIATION THAT
WORK ON THESE CASES.
THANK YOU.
I ARCHER AYE VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS HEATHER SCOTT ON BEHALF
OF STATE COMPTROLLER BETTY OTHER
CONTROLLER IS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL HAD.
CHANGING THE TREATMENT PERIOD
FROM THREE YEARS TO FIVE YEARS.
IS AN INHERENTLY DETRIMENTAL TO
THE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY PROGRAM
ON MOST OF THE STATES HAVE BEEN
TRENDING IN THE DIRECTION OF.
FURY YEARS I'M OF DORMANCY
BEFORE. PROPERTY SHEETS TO THE
STATE I WILL ALSO SAY THAT IT IS
MORE DIFFICULT TO FIND PROPERTY
HOLDERS ONE SON PROPERTY OWNERS
ONCE.
IF SHIPMENT CARRIED GETS LONGER.
RECORDS GO COLD PEOPLE MOVE.
PEOPLE CAN PASS AWAY AND THE
SOONER THAT THE STATE GETS.
IT'S THE FUNDS THEN IT'S EASIER
TO FIND THEM LAST YEAR THE STATE
SENT OUT A MILLION AND A HALF
NOTICES TO POTENTIAL CLAIMANTS.
ANTI WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY I
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SING NOT I'M GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO I THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I AM RECOMMENDING A NO
VOTE ON THIS.
BILL THERE'S BEEN A LONG HISTORY
WITH RESPECT TO.
THE. DOCTRINES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND THEY DID THEN
FIFTEEN YEARS IT'S NOW DOWN TO
THREE YEARS. IN ORDER TO MOVE.
THESE ACCOUNTS HOW TO THE STATE
AND HOPEFULLY GET A BETTER HAVE
A BETTER CHANCE OF.
RECOVERY SO I DON'T SEE THAT
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY AT THIS
POINT I THINK THE PROCESS.
EXISTS.
AS IT EXISTS WORKS REASONABLY
WELL.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THIRTY
SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMETS QUESTION.
SEEING NONE COLOR.
LUXURY MIKLOS.
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK RIO.
I VOTE.
BUT ROUGHLY STONE NO STONE NO
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU NO CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA NO KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I'VE
REYES.
RATES NOW.
NOT YOUR THE VOTE IS TWO TO FIVE
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
NO OTHER AUTHORS OTHER THAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER KALRA
YOU READY TO PRESENTS.
OKAY IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WE'LL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS A BE.
TWO ZERO NINE ZERO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING.
FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS A PERSON
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE TO
APPLY FOR LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS IF THEY ARE GRANTED
SPECIAL IMMIGRATION JUVENILE
STATUS IN CALIFORNIA MANY YOUTH
BETWEEN THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE WERE UNABLE TO
ACQUIRE THE FINDINGS FROM THE
SUPERIOR COURT NECESSARY TO
OBTAIN SPECIAL. IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS
THIS WAS DUE TO THE INABILITY OF
THE COURT OF A PROBATE COURTS TO
TAKE JURISDICTION OF INDIVIDUALS
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND
ESTABLISH GUARDIANSHIP OF THAT
PERSON.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AB NINE
HUNDRED WAS SIGNED INTO LAW TO
LEAVE EIGHT THE SITUATION BY
CREATING PROBATE GUARDIANSHIP
FOR UNMARRIED YOUTH BETWEEN THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY ONE.
AFTER ENACTMENT OF AB NINE
HUNDRED HOWEVER THERE HAS BEEN
CONFUSION REGARDING WHO CAN
PETITION FOR GUARDIANSHIP.
IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER RELATIVE
OR ANY OTHER PERSON INTENDS TO
INCLUDE PARENTS IN SOME CASES A
PARENT IS THE ONLY RELATIVE THE
INDIVIDUAL HOUSE.
THIS VAGUENESS IN STATUTE WAS
PER.
WAS PREVENTED HAS PREVENTED
CERTAIN APPLICANTS FOR SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS FROM
BEING SUBMITTED DUE TO
UNCERTAINTY WHETHER GUARDIANSHIP
WILL BE ESTABLISHED WITH THE
PARENT AT THE PETITIONER.
WHEN THE GUARDIANSHIP IS NOT
ESTABLISHED USED IS NOT RECEIVE
THE NECESSARY FINDINGS
ULTIMATELY PREVENTED FROM
APPLYING FOR THE STATUS AB
TWENTY NINETY ADDRESSES THIS
AMBIGUITY IN STATE LAW BY
CLARIFYING THAT PARENT IS
AUTHORIZED TO FILE A PETITION
FOR GUARDIANSHIP.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
CAMILLA.
KAMALA ALVAREZ SORRY.
MY.
EYES OUR PLANE ADJUSTMENT TRICKS
ON ME NOT GETTING OLD.
WITH CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE
CENTER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS CAMILLE ALVAREZ I AM A
MANAGING ATTORNEY OF THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR
REPRESENTATION PROJECT OF THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE
ARCHITECTS AND OF LOS ANGELES. I
WANNA START BY THINKING ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GONZALEZ. FLETCHER FOR
PROPOSING AB TWENTY NINETY AT A
TIME WHERE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
LIVE IN FEAR AND UNCERTAINTY
IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STEP IN TO DEFEND
THEM.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS FOR ABOUT
TWO YEARS BUT I HAVE WORK TO
HELP IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ARE MUCH
LONGER. IN WORKING WITH
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES OVERWHELMING
SENTIMENT FROM EVERY PERSON I'VE
WORKED WITH IS THE DESIRE FOR A
BETTER LIFE. PARTICULARLY IN
WORKING WITH PARENTS OF
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN I CAN SAY
CONFIDENTLY THAT ALMOST EVERY
PARENT THAT I WORK WITH MONTHS
PROVIDE THEIR CHILDREN WITH A
SAFE AND SECURE FUTURE. BY
ENACTING AB TWENTY NINETY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WILL GIVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARENTS.
AB TWENTY NINETY CLARIFIES
EXISTING STATE LAW THAT ALLOWS
FOR GUARDIANSHIP TO BE GRANTED
TO USE WHO ARE OVER EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD BUT BELOW THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. A. B. NIGHT TWENTY
NINETY DOES NOT CHANGE EXISTING
LAW AND ANYWAY IT JUST CLARIFIES
THAT THE PHRASE A RELATIVE OR
ANY OTHER PERSON INCLUDES
PARENTS OF USE UNDER TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE. WHILE THIS CLEVER
KITCHEN MAY SEEM SMALL IT WOULD
PROVIDE ENORMOUS BENEFITS TO A
CLASS OF USE HER IN NEED OF
EXTRA SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE FROM
THEIR PARENTS IN AN OFFICIAL
CAPACITY. I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
TIME TO GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES
OF YOUNG THE TYPE OF YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT AB TWENTY NINETY
WOULD BENEFIT.
THE FIRST IS A YOUNG MAN THAT I
WORKED WITH FOR THE PAST YEAR
AND A HALF.
THIS YOUNG MAN IS TWENTY YEARS
OLD AND TO THE UNITED STATES
WITH HIS YOUNGER BROTHER AND
SISTER IN ORDER TO FREE FROM
VIOLENCE IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY
OF THEM TO ADDRESS.
WHEN THIS YOUNG MAN ENTERED THE
COUNTRY HE WAS ONLY SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD SADLY HIS MOTHER SAID
AND SIBLINGS FELL PREY TO AN
ATTORNEY THAT DEPLETE VIRTUALLY
NOTHING FOR HIS FAMILY FOR ABOUT
TWO YEARS OTHER THAN TAKE THEIR
MONEY. BY THE TIME GOT US AND.
INHERITED THE CASE THIS YOUNG
MAN HAD ALREADY TURNED EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD AND DID NOT HAVE MANY
OPTIONS FOR LEGAL RELIEF.
HIS YOUNGER SIBLINGS HOWEVER
WERE UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN
AND HAD A VIABLE CASE FOR
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS BASED ON THE ABANDONMENT
OF THE SAME FATHER.
BECAUSE THE OLDER SIBLING WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD THE FAMILY
COURTS JURISDICTION DID NOT
EXTEND TO HEAD THE OLDEST
SIBLING AND HE DID NOT HAVE THE
SAME OPTION. EVEN THOUGH ALL
THREE SIBLINGS WERE ABANDONED BY
THEIR FATHERS WITHIN SIX MONTHS
OF BEING RETAINED WE WERE ABLE
TO OBTAIN SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE FINDINGS FOR THE
YOUNGER TWO SIBLINGS HOWEVER THE
OLDER SIBLINGS OUT OF LUCK ALL
TUBE. ALL DUE TO THE MISS ADVICE
OF ONE ATTORNEY AND HIS AGE THE
CLARIFICATION MAY BE A BIT MADE
BY AB TWENTY NINETY WOULD
PROVIDE AN OPTION FOR A OF
RELIEF TO YOU SUCH AS THIS YOUNG
MAN. THIS YOUNG MAN IS
INCREDIBLY BRAVE AND BRIGHT HE
WANTS NOTHING MORE THAN TO
REMAIN IN THE UNITED STATES OF
HIS FAMILY AND WORK TOWARDS A
BETTER LIFE. THIS YOUNG MAN IS
SO DETERMINED TO SUCCEED IN THE
UNITED STATES HE TRAVELS AROUND
TWO HOURS TWICE A WEEK TO TAKE
ENGLISH CLASSES AT THE CLOSEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. WITH THE
CONSENT OF THIS YOUNG MAN HIS
MOTHER WOULD HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO PETITION THE
PROBATE COURTS FOR LEGAL
GUARDIANSHIP OVER HER SON.
DESERVE RIGHT THIS YOUNG MAN
WITH THE PEACE OF MIND AND SENSE
OF SECURITY SECURITY THAT HE IS
FINALLY SAFE AND SECURE WITH HIS
MOTHER IN THE UNITED STATES.
WITHOUT THE CLARIFICATION MADE
BY AB TWENTY NINETY EIGHT THIS
WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE.
WELL AB TWENTY NINETY WOULD
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FOR
UNACCOMPANIED WRITERS IT WOULD
ALSO BENEFIT OTHER IMMIGRANT
YOUTH LIVING IN CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
ANOTHER YOUNG WOMAN WHO WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM THE BECAUSE
I'M AFRAID YOU'RE ABOUT OUT OF
TIME. THANK YOU.
I YOU COULD
WRAP UP.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JEANNE AT THIS LEVEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SAY NOT OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTION.
CUMMINS.
SINGER WAS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU
MAY CLOSE I JUST ASK OUR LIVE
UP.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHOW. CHOW AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
YOU.
MISS RATES ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT.
SO THIS IS ITEM EIGHT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AND
WHILE SHE'S GETTING TO THE DYESS
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. UNLESS SOME
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE ANY ITEMS.
SO MOTION AND A SECOND ON
CONSENT.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE THEMSELVES FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS AB
NINETEEN SIXTY OBERNOLTE AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN
GIPSON.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR
KILEY IN CORK AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY ONE GALLAGHER. AB THIRTY
FORTY SEVEN DALY AND A. B.
THIRTY ONE.
TWELVE GRAYSON.
RIGHT IS RACE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
PROVIDES A MUCH NEEDED INCREASE.
THE COURT REPORTERS FEE FOR
TRANSCRIPTION OF RECORDS.
THE USE OF COURT REPORTERS
CONTINUES TO BE THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND COST EFFECTIVE
METHOD TO MAKE AN ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE VERBATIM RECORD OF
COURT PROCEEDINGS.
AND ACCURATE RECORD IS ESSENTIAL
TO ANY APPEAL.
COURT REPORTERS ARE HIGHLY
SKILLED INDIVIDUALS WERE
PREDOMINANTLY WOMEN.
AND GET PAID EIGHTY THREE CENTS
PER PAGE
A TRANSCRIPTION.
THIS FEE SET BY STATUTE HAS NOT
BEEN INCREASED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY.
WE'RE DISCUSSING ISSUES OF THE
GENDER PAY GAP AND RECOGNIZING
THAT MOST COURT REPORTERS ARE
WOMEN THE FEE IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
OF HOW WOMEN ARE SIMPLY NOT
COMPENSATED. APPROPRIATELY.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES AN INCREMENTAL PAY
INCREASE TO APPROPRIATELY
COMPENSATE COURT REPORTERS FOR
THEIR AFTER HOURS WORK ON
TRANSCRIPTS.
THIS INCREMENTAL PAY INCREASE
WILL TAKE THE CURRENT EIGHTY
THREE CENTS
AND REYES A TWO ONE DOLLAR
THIRTEEN CENTS BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE.
A SMALL INCREMENTAL TRANSCRIPT
FEE INCREASE WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THERE IS GREATER PAY EQUITY
FOR COURT REPORTERS.
A PERFORMING IMPRINT IMPERATIVE
JOB FOR A COURT SYSTEM.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION.
CAROLYN DASHER CAROLINE DASHER
WHO CURRENTLY SERVES AS A COURT
REPORTER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PUTS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU I'M CAROLYN
GUSHER AND I'M THE PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A STATEWIDE
ENTITY WITH THE BROAD MEMBERSHIP
OF OFFICIAL FREELANCE AS WELL AS
CARP PROVIDERS REPORTERS. AND
OUR MEMBERS ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION COURT
REPORTING IS AN HONORABLE
PROFESSION MORE THAN NINETY
PERCENT OF OUR PROFESSION ARE
WOMEN. OUR MEMBERS ARE VERY
PROUD OF THEIR WORK AND THE
CONTRIBUTION THAT THEY GIVE TO
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS.
I'VE BEEN A COURT REPORTER FOR
OVER THIRTY ONE YEARS IN THE LOS
ANGELES COURT ROOMS AND IS THAT
YOU CAN IMAGINE I PRETTY MUCH
SEEN IT ALL AND THE ONE THING I
HAVEN'T SEEN. IT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY HAS BEEN A TRANSCRIPT
RATE INCREASE.
AND THAT'S THE FEE THAT WE
COLLECT FOR PREPARING AND
PRODUCING OUR TRANSCRIPTS AND
WHAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IS
IT OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS ARE
HYBRID EMPLOYEES. FROM NINE TO
FIVE OR EIGHT TO FIVE WORD OR
TYPICAL NORMAL WORKERS IN THE
COURTS WERE PAID A SALARY AND
BENEFITS BUT THEN WE DO OUR
TRANSCRIPTS THAT'S THE EVENING
AND WEEKENDS WE DO NOT RECEIVE
ANY OVERTIME PAY. AND WE'RE NOT
ENTITLED TO OVERTIME PAY AND WE
DON'T ACCURATE. ANY BENEFITS SO
INSTEAD BY STATUTE WERE
DESIGNATED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS.
JUST ABOUT EVERY WEEK ANY COURT
REPORTER HAS TO PUT IN MANY MANY
HOURS AFTER WORK AFTER HOURS
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILY IGNORING
THEIR FAMILIES NOT GOING TO HOLD
THE THINGS. JUST TO PREPARE
THESE TRANSCRIPTS THAT ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED. BY LAW WE
HAVE TO PAY FOR OUR OWN
EQUIPMENT SOFTWARE COVER ALL THE
MATERIALS AND MAINTENANCE.
AND WHERE TAXES INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND SO SINCE THE FEE
WAS SET BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
NINETEEN NINETY. IT HASN'T BEEN
CHANGED.
AND THE LEGISLATURE IS THE ONLY
ENTITY THAT INCREASED CAN
INCREASE THAT THEME.
I ASK COMEY HAVE THE COURT
REPORTERS IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT OUR
TIME IS KIND THAT OUR WORK IS
RESPECTED AND ASK YOU PLEASE TO
SUPPORT THE FLEDGLING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PRESENT NOT
HERNANDEZ ALSO BEHALF OF THE
HEALTH RECORD PORTER
ASSOCIATION.
LET ME JUST LIMIT MY REMARKS TO
ONE ISSUE THAT WASN'T MENTIONED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
THAT IS THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND OF THE TRF.
OF THIS IS A FIND WHICH.
HELPS A INDIGENT LITIGANTS ON
PAY FOR THE TRANSCRIPT.
AND WE. SEE CARRIES VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
THE FUND IS ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
FUNDED.
BY THE LICENSING FEES OF COURSE
VOTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S IT NO BUT NOT
NOTHING FROM THE GENERAL FUND
COMPLETELY FROM THE LICENSES.
LAST YEAR IT REALLY DOES LAST
YEAR CRA SUPPORTED ON EFFORT TO
A AUTHORIZED THE CORPORATE BOARD
TO INCREASE.
THE LICENSING FEES A UP TO A
DOUBLING IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS. THAT DOUBLING
WILL OCCUR MEETING THAT COURT
REPORTERS WILL HAVE TO PAY.
I BELIEVE IT'S JUNE INFIDELITY
YOUR FOR THE LICENSES.
THAT MONEY THEN WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO GO INTO THE
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUND TO
HELP COVER THE COST FOR INDIGENT
LITIGANTS THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE FUN.
I SEE SCARY ACTUALLY HELP
SPONSOR THE INITIAL LEGISLATION
TO CREATE THE FUND
AND HAVE ALWAYS BEEN THERE TOO
UP TO FIGHT FOR THE CONTINUANCE
OF THAT FUND.
I AND OUR HOPE IS THAT WITH THE
LICENSING FEE INCREASE THAT WILL
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT FUNDING.
THERE ANY CHANGES THAT NEED TO
BE DONE ANY TWEAKS TO THAT OR
NEEDS TO BE AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT
OF MONEY PUT INTO THE FUND RIGHT
NOW IT'S THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH YEAR.
WE ARE ACTIVELY HAVING
DISCUSSIONS WITH FOLKS ABOUT
THAT.
I'VE BEEN NEEDS TO BE INCREASED
WITH ADDITIONAL OF MONEY COMING
IN FROM LICENSING FEES. THAT
MONEY WILL BE AVAILABLE WITHIN
GETS OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
AND WE ARE WORKING ON THAT RIGHT
NOW.
SO I JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT
THERE ANY QUESTIONS I CAN
ADJUST.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORTS.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
JUST ONE ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
TWO PREVIOUS WITNESSES COMMENTS
AND IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE
HIS REPORTER'S PARA INCREASE AND
WE ASK FREE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PATRON WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
I'M MISTER CHAIRMAN CHEN GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE I. P. T. E.
LOCAL TWENTY ONE WHICH
REPRESENTS COURT REPORTERS
INCENTIVES CHO. WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
SPORT INCREASE WE DO HAVE ONE
SLIGHT CONCERN WITH THE BILL
THAT MENTIONS A SPECIFIC
REPORTER ORGANIZATION IN THE
TEXT OF THE BILL. THERE ARE
OTHER REPORTER RIGHT INITIATIONS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE A
STAKEHOLDER SO. I'M WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR ON THAT
BUT WE SUPPORT BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
SING NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER KALRA.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR A AND THANK
YOU SOME MEMBER OF THE BRASS
RING OF FOR THIS BILL AS SOMEONE
THAT WORK FOR ELEVEN YEARS THE
DEPUTY OF A DEFENDER I CAN.
ABSOLUTELY TRUST TO THE WORK
THAT WOULD THAT THAT IS DONE
EVERY DAY. FIRE COURT REPORTERS.
AND THE FACT THAT
WE HAVEN'T
SEEN AN INCREASE IN THE RATE.
I IN NO.
WHAT'S THAT NOW TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT HERE FILE.
SO.
ANY CASE AYE I APPRECIATE IT
AND FOR ALL THE TIMES A COURT
REPORTERS TOLD ME TO SLOW DOWN
WHEN I WAS THERE. SPEAKING I
APOLOGIZE I HOPE WITH THIS CAN
HELP A LITTLE BIT ON THAT.
AND SOME OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO SO WHERE WERE
FIGHTING FOR AT
LEAST ENSURING CORE PORTERS ARE
IN FAMILY LAW COURTS AND.
ANYWHERE WE CAN GET THEM BUT.
IT IS A LEGITIMATE ASK AND WE DO
NEED TO KEEP AN EYE ON. MAKING
SURE THAT WE DO HAVE THE. THOSE
INDIGENT LITIGANTS COVER SO
THANK YOU.
DRESS MIKLOS.
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS IS A LONG
TIME TO WAIT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND THE MOST IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU. CHOW AYE CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES AYE REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KALRA.
ARE YOU READY.
I CAN GO.
I ALSO THE VILLA. WHICH I ALWAYS
LIKE TO WAIT UNTIL THE END BUT.
OKAY.
THIS WILL TAKE US THEN.
TO ITEM TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
WITCHES.
BY BILL GONZALEZ FLETCHER
FUTURE.
I WOULD LOVE TO.
IF I THINK I CAN GET USED TO BE
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
APPLAUSE.
HONESTLY. I CAN'T CLOSE OFF
CAMPUS.
MR STONE JACK SEAT. THE TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX.
AND I'M CERTAINLY TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED.
FOISTED UPON ME BY AN
UNREASONABLE CHAIR BUT THAT'S
FINE.
SO TAXPAYER LAWSUITS ARE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC TO KEEP.
JURISDICTIONS ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THERE'S A RECENT SUPREME
COURT CASE THAT SEEMS TO WANT TO
LIMIT IT TO THOSE WHO PAY
PROPERTY TAX WHICH DOESN'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE SINCE THAT THAT'S
A A SUBSET OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING. IN ANY THE JURISDICTIONS
AND FOR TRULY ONE USES TOOL.
TO HOLD JURISDICTIONS
ACCOUNTABLE WE NEED TO EXPAND
THE HANDS IN FACT IN THAT
DECISION THE SUPREME COURT. ASK
THE LEGISLATURE TO CLARIFY THIS
PARTICULAR SECTION AND ENSURED
THAT THAT WE ARE COVERING.
TAXES THAT ONE WOULD ASSUME
WOULD BE COVERED BY THIS BILL
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
EXPANDS. THOSE WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO HAVE STANDING TO
BRING A SUIT AGAINST A
JURISDICTION BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
FACT TAXPAYERS.
WITH THAT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTES
AND I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I GOOD MORNING I'M GEN FLORES
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
WHICH WOULD CLARIFY WHICH
TAXPAYERS CONCERT STANDING IN
TAXPAYER LAWSUITS. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
STAFF FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
THAT'S.
I WESTERN CENTER HAS HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF USING TAXPAYER
STANDING SUITS TO ASSERT THEIR
RIGHTS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
FOR EXAMPLE IN SERRANO THE
PRIEST THE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
CASE THAT INVALIDATED A
CALIFORNIA'S UNJUST SCHOOL FIGHT
MANSINGH SYSTEM THAT BECAME
BEGAN AS A TAXPAYER STANDING
SUIT AGAINST THE LA BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE WON
HANSEN VERSUS DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES A TAXPAYERS STANDING
CASE THAT ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
COULD NOT BE DENIED ASSISTANCE.
ON THE BASIS THAT THEY WERE
HOMELESS.
HOWEVER NINETEEN NINETY THREE
THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEALS
IN TAURUS FOUND THAT SALES TAX
BECAUSE IT'S TECHNICALLY PAID BY
THE RETAILER. COULD NOT CONFER
TAXPAYERS STANDING STATUS
TRY TELLING A CONSUMER AT A CASH
REGISTER WHO'S JUST BEEN CHARGED
TO SALES TAX THAT THEY'RE NOT IN
FACT PAYING SALES TAX.
AS A RESULT IT BECAME UNCLEAR
WHICH TAXES COULD CONFER
STANDING. TO MANY IT SEEMED
PROPERTY TAXES WERE THE ONLY
SAFE TAXES EFFECTIVELY BLOCKING
LOW INCOME PEOPLE FOR ASSERTING
THEIR RIGHTS IN COURT.
FAST FORWARD TO TWENTY THIRTEEN.
CHARITY WEATHERFORD DECIDES TO
CHALLENGE HER CITIES PRACTICE OF
AND POUNDING PEOPLE'S CARS
WITHOUT NOTICE.
DESPITE THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE
LAW ON THE FACT THAT SHE IS NOT
A PROPERTY TAXPAYER MS WHETHER
FOR DESSERT SHE PLACED PAYS
PLENTY OF TAXES
INCLUDING SALES TAX GAS TAX
WATER AND SEWAGE FEES. SO THAT
SHE SHOULD HAVE STANDING BOTH
THE TRIAL COURT AND THE COURT OF
APPEAL FIND THAT PROPERTY TAXES
REQUIRE TO CONVERSE STANDING AND
REJECT HER ARGUMENT THAT
REQUIRING PROPERTY TAX IS
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON WEALTH.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
REVIEWED HER CASE AND
SPECIFICALLY SAID THAT ONE NEED
NOT PAIR PROPERTY TAX TO HAVE
STANDING.
BUT THEY ALSO NOTED THE ARCHAIC
AND UNCLEAR LANGUAGE OF THE
STATUTE AND REQUESTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE ACTION TO
CLARIFY THE STATUTE.
WHICH BRINGS US TO TODAY.
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IS ASKING THIS BODY TO
REOPEN OUR TAXPAYERS STANDING
STATUE TO CLARIFY THAT ALL PAIRS
OF TAXES HAVE STANDING. PROVIDED
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A CONNECTION
TO THE DEFENDANT GOVERNMENT.
THIS INCLUDES THOSE TAXES SUCH
AS SALES TAX WHICH MAY NOT BE A
DIRECT PAYMENT BUT ABSOLUTELY
COME OUT AT THE TAXPAYER'S
POCKET TO FUND THE DEFENDING
GOVERNMENT. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
ARE PAID BY THE LESS WEALTHY
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
FINALLY WERE ALSO ASKING THAT
THE WORD CITIZEN BE DELETED FROM
THE STATUTE TO ENSURE THAT TAX
PAIN IMMIGRANTS ALSO SHARE THE
RIGHT TO CHALLENGE THE MISUSE OF
THEIR TAXES.
IN ESSENCE OF OPRAH TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY REPRESENTS
THE NOTION THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO ALLOWED FOR A TAXPAYER
STANDING STATUE IN THIS STATE.
THAN WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW ALL
RESIDENTS TO USE IT. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND AND.
ANOTHER WITNESS PART.
VERY BRIEFLY MADAM CHAIR KEVIN
BAKER FOR THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO USED TO STATURE FREQUENTLY.
ALL TAXPAYERS SHOULD BE AND ABLE
TO CHALLENGE GOVERNMENT WASTE
FRAUD AND ABUSE THAT'S WHAT
MAKES THE SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE BUT
IT'S NOT JUST SORT OF. MORE
PROGRESSIVE GROUPS.
IT'S ALSO GROUPS ON ON THE
BRIGHTON AND TAXPAYER GROUPS I'M
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR EYES.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CARE
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE FREQUENTLY HAVE TO
TURN TO THE COURTS TO ENFORCE
RIGHTS OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SO WE SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT ON TAKING THAT CLOUD
THAT. HANGS OVER ON TAXPAYER
STANDING SO WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS CLEAR FOR FUTURE
CASES THANK YOU.
MIKE WE ON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ROSSI HER
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
ANY QUESTIONS.
LIKE MANY.
THE CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ISP RATHER.
HE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO PASS AS AMENDED STONE.
I STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. RACE.
REYES I.
THE BILL GETS OUT.
THINK IT.
SO HAPPILY HIS ADULTS O. WE'VE
CHALLENGED OUR PROBE SHARE.
TWO RUNNING POLICY COMMITTEE
INTEREST.
ALRIGHT SO MUCH COLOR YOU READY
OKAY.
SO WE WILL NOW TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN.
KALRA
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN WOULD
PROVIDE A TECHNICAL FIX A TO.
FORMER SENATOR STEINBERG'S
CURRENT MAYOR STEINBERG'S SP
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
WHICH ACQUIRES FOR LABOR
CONTRACTORS OR FLC IS TO
REGISTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD ENSURE THE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF SP FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN BY REQUIRING THAT
ALL HAVE FOUND SEES AS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED. ARE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER WITH THE
COMMISSION NOT JUST THOSE
RECRUIT WORKERS WITH AGE TO BE.
VISA CATEGORY.
THIS INTENTION HAS BEEN LAID OUT
BY NOW MAYOR STEINBERG AND
SEVERAL LETTERS LEGISLATURE'S
MAZA PRESLEY'S ON THE ISSUE OF
THE FAULTY IMPLEMENTATION.
AS ESTABLISHED BY S. BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT POLICIES TO
REGISTER WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
TO HIRE REGISTERED A POLICIES
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY PROVIDES
PROTECTIONS AND REMEDIES FOR
THOSE FOREIGN WORKERS SOLICITED
AND RECRUITED TO WORK
TEMPORARILY IN CALIFORNIA.
PROTECT THEM FROM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND OTHER LABOR CODE
VIOLATIONS.
LABOR AND SEX TRAFFICKING
CONTINUE TO BE A PERVASIVE ISSUE
IN THE SOLICITATION AND HIRING
OF FOREIGN WORKERS UNDER ALL
VISA CATEGORIES.
OUR SPONSOR AB WORK BUT MANY
SUCH INDIVIDUALS.
GUSTAVO TO FORTY I'LL DORADO WAS
RECRUITED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE MITCHELL CON
MEXICO TO WORK CALIFORNIA I'M
AGE TO A. B. SEPARATENESS
ROBBERIES HE AND THE OTHER FOUR
HUNDRED WORKERS WERE PART OF
THIS CASE WERE CHARGE.
MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN KICKBACKS RECRUITMENT
COST PLUS ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
TRAVEL.
HE AND HIS CO WORKERS WERE
THREATENED WITH BLACKLISTING. BY
EMPLOYERS AFTER THEY COMPLAINED
ABOUT THESE ABUSES.
THIS TITLE RETALIATION NEEDS TO
BE CURRENT WITH THE PROTECTIONS
LAID OUT SP FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN.
BY LIMITING OF THE SCOPE OF AS
BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN TO APPLE SEES
RECRUITING UNDER THE AGE TO BE
BE SET ONLY THE VAST MAJORITY A
TEMPORARY FOREIGN WORKERS COMING
TO CALIFORNIA REMAIN UNPROTECTED
AND SUBJECT.
THE DOCUMENT ABUSES OF
UNSCRUPULOUS AT POLICIES.
INSTEAD OF PROTECTING OVER A ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TEMPORARY
WORKERS COMING TO CALIFORNIA.
ITS PROTECTIONS ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE TO ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND TEMPER AGE TO BE
WORKERS. AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN
PHOTOS THE INTENT OF SP FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT ALL FOREIGN LABOR
CONTRACTORS ARE COVERED. WITH
ONLY TWO EXCEPTIONS J. ONE VISAS
AND TALENT AGENCY RECRUITERS
THAT BOTH HAVE MORE STRINGENT
STANDARDS.
AS A RESULT THE BILL WOULD ALIGN
LA TO COMPORT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AT POLICIES
RECRUITING.
WORKERS UNDER ALL BASIC
CATEGORIES
AKA ARE COVERED BY COVERING ALL
AT BELL SEES AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ONE SURE THAT ALL FARMWORKERS
ARE PROTECTED AGAINST WAY EXCEPT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND OTHER
WORKER ABUSES.
ALTHOUGH STAKEHOLDERS IN
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY OF OPPOSE
THE BILL FOR US TO GROW UP. IN
THE FOOT WITH THEIR ARGUMENT
IT'S DUPLICATIVE IN NATURE. OF
THEM WITH FARM LABOR CONTRACTING
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
NECESSARY PICKS BECAUSE THE TWO
ARE NOT ONE OF THE SAME.
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS OFTEN
HIGHER FOREIGN LABOR RECRUITERS
TO HANDLE INTERNATIONAL LABOR.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT PLACE A
DUPLICATIVE BURDEN ON THE FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS BUT DOES
REQUIRE THOSE CONTRACTORS TO
HIRE RECRUITERS ARE IN
COMPLIANCE.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TEST MONEY ARE STEPPING RICHARD
FROM THE COALITION AGAINST LABOR
AND TRAFFICKING PROFILE BATISTA
A SURVIVOR ADVOCATE WHO ESCAPE
FROM HUMANE TRAPPING SITUATION.
TO BECOME A PARALEGAL AND MEMBER
OF SEVERAL SURVIVOR NETWORKS AND
A CAIRO MANUALS REPRESENTING THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE FOR THE CITY OF
SEGMENT.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS BUT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE RICHARD I'M TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
TO ABOLISH SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING CAST.
AS THE BILL'S SPONSOR.
THIS IS A TECHNICAL CORRECTION
DISCLAIMERS SP FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
WHICH YOU ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
MISTER CHAIR WHEN I STOOD BEFORE
YOU IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. ASKING FOR
THE SAME THING THAT THEY'RE A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND AND NOW
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
TEMPORARY WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS.
ON A TUBA TO PROTECT THEM FROM
FOR THE FRAUDULENT PRACTICES
AFFORD LABOR RECRUITERS THAT
LEAD TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
EXPLOITATION.
THE QUESTION BEFORE YOU A
SIMPLE.
IS IT GOOD POLICY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS TO ALL
TEMPORARY WORKERS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA.
I BELIEVE THE ANSWER IS YES
BASED ON MY FIRST HAND ON THE
GROUND EXPERIENCE OF TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I ALSO BELIEVE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
ALREADY ANSWERED THIS QUESTION
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHEN SP
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A DRAFTING
ERROR.
THAT THE BILL WAS INSERTED
UNDER SECTION THAT EXPLICITLY
STATED THAT IT ONLY APPLIED TO
EACH TO BE WORKERS THAT MEANS IT
ONLY COVERS THREE THOUSAND
WORKERS NOT THE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND WORKERS WE
REGULARLY DISCUSSED.
IN ALL THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN NONSENSICAL FOR PASSED THE
COMMON FRONT OF YOU. ALONG WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THEN THE PER TAM
AT THE TIME AND I HOUSE FOR A
BILL THAT WITH LIMITED SOLELY TO
THE EACH TO BE CLASS.
HAD THAT BEEN THE CASE ALSO WE
HAVE IT WOULD HAD NO NEED TO
ENGAGE IN EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS
AND DISCUSSIONS WHICH I WAS
PERSONALLY PART OF.
COMPROMISE WITH THE J. ONE LOBBY
AND OTHER BUSINESS GROUPS TO
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDE CERTAIN
CATEGORIES.
AT THAT TIME.
THE PROTECTIONS UNDER S. B. FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ARE ESSENTIAL
PERFECT PROTECTING ALL TEMPORARY
WORKERS AND DESIGNED TO BE A
UNIFORM POLICY. ACROSS
CATEGORIES THOUGH THAT WORKERS
AND EMPLOYERS HAVE CONSISTENT
WERE.
REGULATION.
I ALSO WANT TO VOTE. NOTE THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REALLY
DID FOCUS ON EACH TO A WORKERS
WHICH IS ONLY ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND TO FIVE THOUSAND
WORKERS.
BUT THIS FOR A FOCUS FORGET
ABOUT ALL THE OTHER VISA
CATEGORIES THAT ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED WHICH INCLUDE
A THREE G. FIVE EACH ONE B. O.
IP YOU THREE TN EXCEPT ROB.
AND WHAT I WANT TO SAY IS THAT
WHEN HE TESTIFIED IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
WAS THAT THERE ARE NUMEROUS
REPORTS AND DOCUMENTATIONS THAT
THE GREATEST WAY TO PREVENT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND LABOR
EXPLOITATION. IS TO PROTECT
TEMPORARY WORKERS AT THE POINT
OF RECRUITMENT REGARDLESS OF THE
BEAST THE CATEGORY AND THAT IS
THE NEW PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
JUST NOT EVER SIMPLY CULVERT IN
CALIFORNIA LOBBY FOR FEDERALLY.
AND THAT'S WHAT I REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THESE PROTECTIONS
COVER UP THE TIME A
SOLICITATION.
FOR THE WORK AND THAT'S WHEN WE
SEE THAT WORKERS OR PROVIDED
WITH FALSE INFORMATION DO THINGS
LIKE TAKE ON THAT.
UP UP UP QUIT JOBS AT THE OR D.
HAVE BECAUSE THEY'RE MADE FALSE
PROMISES SO THAT THE MAJOR NEW
PROTECTION THIS BILL REQUIRES
THAT THAT INFORMATION BE
PROVIDED AT THE POINT OF
SOLICITATION NUCLEAR AS WELL AS.
AND THEN FINALLY ON ONE THING
THAT CAME UP WITH THE BONDING
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS.
THERE'S REQUIRED FOR BOTH FOR
IN LATE FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
AND FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTORS.
WE MADE VERY CONSIDERABLE
CONCESSIONS THAT INVOLVED
REMOVING A CRIMINAL LIABILITY
FROM EMPLOYERS REMOVING IN.
JOINT AND SEVERAL LIABILITY
FROM A PLAYER'S AND IT WAS AT
THAT TIME THAT THIS VERY
COMMITTEE SAID THAT IS WHEN YOU
SHOULD INCREASE THE BODY
REQUIREMENTS IN THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY. TO PROTECT THE WEARER
DO NOT TO MEET THEIR ALPHA SO I
THINK YOU FOR.
YOUR VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING WITNESS PLEASE
MORNING MY NAME IS ROUGH I WROTE
THE STUFF YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY.
I'M A SURVIVOR OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING I'M ORIGINALLY FROM
MEXICO CITY MEXICO.
AND I.
I WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY DURING
THE TWO YEARS THAT I WAS A
FORCED TO WORK FOR MY TRAFFICKER
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
HE WILL TELL ME THAT WAS NOT DAY
OFF MY WORK TIES WERE ALL
CONSUMING.
SOMETIMES I WAS ABLE TO SLEEP
ONLY FOR THREE TO FOUR HOURS PER
NIGHT OTHERWISE I'D BE WORKING
MOST OF THE TIME.
WHEN I SCAPE I WAS BLESSED TO
MEET MY SOCIAL WORKER WHO HELPED
ME UNDERSTAND THAT I WAS A
VICTIM OF TWENTY PERCENTERS
LABORING.
I THOUGHT THEIR OWN DOCUMENT
THAT PERSON WILL SALFORD THESE
HORRIFIC CRIME BUT I WAS WRONG
AFTER BECOMING ACTIVE IN THIS
MOVEMENT.
I GUESS HUMAN TRAFFICKING I
LEARNED THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY
MORE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THAT CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY WITH THE LEGAL WORK BE
SACKED. ANY WORSE OFF THAN WHEN
THEY STARTED TRACKING
EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE MADE SEVERAL STE FELLOW
SURVIVORS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
OTHER PLACES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WERE ACTUALLY WORSE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAN ME.
ALTHOUGH THEY CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES WITH THE LEGAL WORK VISA
THESE FELLOWS NOT ONLY HAVE
SEVERE FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES. BUT
ALSO FOR THEIR FAMILIES IN THEIR
HOMETOWN.
OF.
WHERE THEY WERE RECRUITED BY A?
LABOR CONTRACTORS.
MANY TIMES THEY TOOK A LOT OF
THE ABSENT THEY EVEN SELL THEIR
LANDS TO BE ABLE TO PAY THE
DEBTS TO COME TO THE UNITED
STATES.
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY.
BOB THESE BE SAYS THEY WERE
COMING ON WILL GET THEM A GREEN
CAR.
AND THEN THE TEMPORARY WAR WAS
ONLY FOR THREE TO SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE THEY CALL NOT PAY.
THAT THEY HAVE THEY TOOK IN.
THERE WERE AFRAID TO FUND WILL
HAPPEN TO THEIR FAMILY. WORKERS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE PAIN RECRUITMENT
FREEZE FOR TEMPORARY WORK VISAS
TO COME TO UNITED STATES. THEY
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT TURNS
AND CONTRACTS THEY ARE COMING ON
THEIR.
OWN THEIR AND THAT THESE
CONTRACTS TERMS CANNOT BE
CHANGED THEY NEED. THEY NEED A
WAY TO FIND A LIST OF SAVED
RECRUITMENT. OR TRUST TO GIVE
THEM.
LEGITIMATE JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA THE
PROTECTIONS IN AS BEFORE SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL HELP SO MANY WORKERS
AND PREVENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WAS SO SAD TO LEARN THAT IS
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN. WHICH WAS
A PASSENGER DOESN'T FOURTEEN AND
SHOULDN'T.
ENSURE HAVE GONE INTO EFFECT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IS STILL
NOT PROVIDING THE PROTECTION TO
ALL TEMPORARY WORKERS.
WHO NEED IT? I CAN ENSURE THAT
BY PASSING.
I CAN ASSURE YOU.
BASED ON MY OWN AND OTHER
SURVIVORS EXPERIENCE THAT THESE
DELAY MEANS THE MANY MORE
WORKERS COMING TO CALIFORNIA
HAVING TRAFFIC.
AND SUBJECT TO OWN PER PAGE
WAGES
CONDITIONS AND ABUSE.
THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
SUFFERING RIGHT NOW AND REALLY
FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES PLEASE
VOTING SUPPORT BUT TODAY FOR IS.
FOR A. B. ELEVEN NINETY TWO TO
PROTECT WORKERS LIKE ME AND
OTHER SURVIVORS THAT I KNOW.
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
IT MONEY MISTER CHAIR CARROT
MANUALS ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
MAYOR DEL STEINBERG ON THIS
BILL.
I'M IS THE AUTHOR OF BEST BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN IT'S A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTEEN IS NEEDED TO
RESTORE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT WITH
EXPRESSLY ON REGARDS TO
PROTECTION FROM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. WHICH THE
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME A PROBLEM
IN SACRAMENTO BECAUSE OF THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
MODESTO RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
FEET JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE GOOD MORNING
MELANIE QUIT ES ON BEHALF OF
CENTRO DE LOS THAT.
CHEST MICRONS HAY AS WELL AS
CAST THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING THINK
YOU.
FLOW INTO MEDINA WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS CHUNKS PART.
STENA CAVANAUGH VOLUNTEER FOR
SHARED HOPE INTERNATIONAL IN
SUPPORT ALSO SACRAMENTO FRIENDS
ANY TRAFFICKING GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MIKE WE ON THE MAP THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
NICOLAS HOW HIS ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
COULD YOU CLEAR THE TABLE PLEASE
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THOUGHT.
THAT THE SONG IS ABOUT.
I'M BRIAN LITTLE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND I'M HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
OPPOSITION DAY BE NINETEEN
THIRTEEN.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN IMPOSES AN ADDITIONAL.
REPUBLICAN OF REGULATORY
INFRASTRUCTURE
ON FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS TO USE
THE H. TO A PROGRAM.
WE VIA FARM LABOR CONTRACTOR
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
CURRENT STATE LAW IN ADDITION TO
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR USERS OF
THE H. TO A. TEMPORARY NON
IMMIGRANT VISA PROGRAM.
I ALREADY PROVIDE AMPLE
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS THAT ARE
WORKING CALIFORNIA UNDER THIS
PROGRAM.
AND SO OUR CONCERN IS THAT YOU
WILL HAVE THE EFFECT OF
DISCOURAGING. FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS FROM ENGAGING IN
FOREIGN LABOR CONTRACTING
ACTIVITY AND FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS PUT.
PERFORM A VERY IMPORTANT
FUNCTION.
FOR OUR CULTURE CALIFORNIA BEING
THE GO BETWEEN BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS WHO DON'T HAVE
PERFECT INFORMATION ABOUT
SEASONS AND AVAILABILITY OF
WORKERS.
ALLOW GROWERS TO HAVE MORE
CONTINUOUS SUPPLY OF LABOR AND
MORE RELIABLE SUPPLY OF LABOR IN
ALLOW WORKERS TO WORK MORE WEEKS
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
IMPROVING THEIR INCOME.
AND SO IN THE OVERALL SENSE OF
THE CONCERN WE HAVE ABOUT THIS.
ASSEMBLY.
DUPLICATIVE REGULATION OF FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS ARE ENGAGING
IN THE H. TO A PROGRAM FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS WITHOUT GOOD
MORNING MATTHEW ARNOLD WAS FROM
GORGEOUS SOCIAIS XIN I WOULD
LARGELY LARGELY ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY A MISTER LITTLE
FROM THE FARM BUREAU. OF YOU
KNOW THIS WAS THESE DISCUSSIONS
OCCURRED BACK IN AS BEFORE
SEVENTY SEVEN S. B. FIVE SIXTEEN
THE PREVIOUS BILL THAT I ALSO
MADE IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
A WE BELIEVE IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S
THIS IS NOT A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
OF THE BILL IT'S VERY EXPLICIT
IN THE STATUTE THAT IS NOT
APPLICABLE TO THE H. TO A
WORKERS WHO ARE COVERED UNDER
THE EXISTING FIVE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTING PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF OF BEING EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT HAS DIMINISHED WAGE
THEFT IN OUR INDUSTRY. AND OUR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING LOVE FROM EVER
CONTRACTORS ALSO HAVE A SPECIFIC
POSTING REQUIREMENT THAT UNIQUE
TO OUR INDUSTRY WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND WE
HAVE TO DO THAT SPECIFIC POSTING
REQUIREMENT. THROUGH THE AG AT
THAT OUR WORKPLACES
SO OUR INDUSTRY IS HEAVILY
REGULATED HERE WERE RIGHT ABOUT.
AN UNNECESSARY DUPLICATIVE
REGULATIONS THIS POINT.
THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
AND OPPOSITION.
MARTY FISHER CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL KNOW THE COMPOSITION Y.
GROUP GROWERS WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS THAT THERE.
ARE PROTECTIONS NEEDED FOR THE
WORKERS WE ALSO BE IMPEACHED FOR
THAT HOUSES POST PROTECTIONS ARE
EXISTING FEDERAL LAW. IS BILLS
UNNECESSARY WERE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THAT.
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT TENER
STEINBERG MENTOR NOT MEANT.
TROUBLES ME TO THE EXTENT THAT
AS I'VE LEARNED SINCE I'VE BEEN
CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FORMER CHAIR.
NEVER MAKE MISTAKES SO I'M NOT.
CAN'T ADMIT THAT SENATOR
STEINBERG MADE A MISTAKE.
AND BESIDES IT'S MOOT BECAUSE
WHAT'S BEFORE US IS SOMETHING
THAT THIS BODY THIS LEGISLATURE
IS FRITO MAD IN ANY CASE.
AND.
YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT MISTER KALRA
ON THIS BILL THE ONE THING THAT
I DO WANT TO RAISE WHICH WAS
RAISE THE ANALYSIS IS THAT
SINCE.
WE ARE ADDING IN IT AND IT IS
SOME QUESTIONABLE ABOUT WHETHER.
FARMERS ARE. HIGHER FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS OR NOT THERE IS A
POTENTIAL FOR DUPLICATIVE FEES
DUPLICATIVE.
BONDING THE WAY THIS IS
POTENTIALLY SET UP IT'S IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ISSUE HERE BUT I
HOPE IS THIS MOVES FORWARD THAT
THAT.
ESSENTIALLY GETS ADDRESSED AND
ANSWERED SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE ADDING.
WE DON'T WANT ON TOP OF THE
OTHER WHERE IT'S NOT JUSTIFIED
OR WHETHER IT'S NOT.
NOT A REASON FOR THEIR COULD BE
REASON FOR IT THERE. DEPENDING
ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WAS
NOT NECESSARILY.
CLEAR IN THAT SENTENCE IT WAS
PHRASED AS CLEANING UP THEN
I DON'T KNOW THAT. THAT LET'S
LET'S LOOK AHEAD LET'S LOOK AT
THIS POLICY ON ITS OWN AND MAKE
SURE THAT IT MAKES SENSE IN THE
BROADER CONTEXT THAT'S ALL THAT
I'M ASKING.
OTHER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND AND THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE CALLER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AND I'D ABSOLUTELY TAKE YOUR.
CONSIDERATION AS WELL AS YOUR
STAFF AND AND IN THE REPORT AND
AND WILL CERTAINLY.
TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
WITH WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. I
AND I DO OF AS INDICATED THINK A
YOU KNOW THE THE THE VIGOROUS.
.
PUT CONVERSATIONS THAT OCCURRED.
WHEN SENATOR STEINBERG IS
PUTTING THIS FORWARD ARE
OBSOLETE RELEVANT HOWEVER I DO
ALSO AGREED THAT REGARDLESS OF
THAT HIS TONE IMPORTANT BILL. I
OR TO PROTECT WORKERS A AND THE
INTENSELY NOT TO CREATE
DUPLICATIVE EITHER FEES OR
REGULATION BUT ACTUALLY. UP
THERE ARE MEANINGFUL PROTECTIONS
UNIQUE TO THEIR RECRUITMENT OF
FOREIGN LABOR.
THAT APPLY AND PLUS WE CANNOT
ESCAPE THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WE'RE SEEING THE BALL BACK
OF MANY REGULATIONS THAT PROTECT
WORKERS AND SO.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A ALSO A. A A
WAY OF BEING PROACTIVE TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROTECT OUR WORKERS THE
BEST EXTENT POSSIBLE. AS WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN
THE MOST IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHOW. CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BLOOM.
IT'S TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
.
IS LOOKING FOR MY WITNESS MISTER
CHAIR.
WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL WE COULD
TAKE UP IF YOU NEED TO WAIT A
LITTLE BIT.
IT'S HERE OKAY.
LET'S PROCEED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR WHICH.
UPDATES THE UNIFORM PARENTAGE
ACTS IN A OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
U. P. A.
YOU PAY WAS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO ELIMINATE
DISCRIMINATORY TREATMENT OF NON
MARITAL CHILDREN AND TWO YEARS
AGO. THE UNIFORM LA COMMISSION A
NON PARTISI PARTISAN ADVISORY
GROUP FOR THE U. PA AUTHORIZED
TO REVISION OF THE UPI TO ENSURE
EQUAL PROTECTION. FOR CHILDREN
OF SAME SEX COUPLES.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR
INCORPORATES THESE CHANGES FROM
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE.
RELEVANT FOR CALIFORNIA LAWS
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE HAS LONG
BEEN A TRAILBLAZER IN PROTECTING
LGBT INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
CHILDREN THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
WE CONTINUE ON THAT PATH AND
UPDATES LAWS. TO REFLECT CURRENT
CULTURE AND TECHNOLOGY.
SPEAK ON THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL.
I HAVE HERE ARE A COUNTY SUCK
MORE FROM THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS AND TO AS
WELL JULIAN BABBLE. MEND YOUR
AND HER CHILD WILL SHARE
THEIR STORY.
IS IT WOULD WHICH ONCE THE
WITNESS THE ONE WITH THE FEAR
ABOUT.
TAKE A WILD GUESS MISTER.
FIRST WITNESS.
YOU THINK YOU THINK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND MAY MISS KATHY
SAKE MORA AND I'M THE FAMILY LAW
DIRECTOR AT THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LESBIAN RIGHTS.
I'M EVERY YEAR WE RECEIVE CALLS
FROM HUNDREDS OF PARENTS SEEKING
TO PROTECT THEIR RIGHTS TO THEIR
CHILDREN. AND OFTEN THE ONLY
OPTION AVAILABLE TO THEM IS TO
GET AN ADOPTION OR A COURT ORDER
WHICH FOR PARENTS OF A NEW BABY
IS QUITE CUMBERSOME. AND CAN BE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE BUT
CALIFORNIA ALREADY PROVIDES A
FREE SIMPLE PROCESS AVAILABLE TO
FATHERS IN HOSPITALS TO PROTECT
THEIR RIGHTS. OMINOUS BILL WOULD
MAKE THAT EQUALLY AVAIL
AVAILABLE TO SAME SEX PARENTS
WHO CONCEIVED THROUGH ASSISTED
REPRODUCTION. IT WOULD ALSO
MODERNIZE CALIFORNIA'S GENETIC
TESTING A PROVISIONS WHICH ARE
OUTDATED. AND WOULD CODIFY
CALIFORNIA CASE LAW ABOUT HOW
GENETIC TESTING IS CONSIDERED IN
CASES INVOLVING NON BIOLOGICAL
PARENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LET'S PUT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOANNE PROBLEM IN THE AREA.
AND I'M THE PROUD MOM I HAVE TWO
KIDS.
ARGUE HIS OUT SLEEPING.
AND.
AND THE FIND HENRY HIS ABOUT TO
TURN ONE.
MY WIFE AND AND I CAN FEEL BOTH
ARGUE AND HOW ARE YOU WHERE.
RE-ATTEMPT.
JUNIOR RAMBOVA.
I MAY HAVE TO VAN YEAH NNOVA.
AND.
WE KNEW FROM THE BEGINNING WE
BOTH KNOW THE BIRTH.
PARAGRAPH I WAS WILLING.
ALRIGHT SO LIKE EVERYTHING MY
LIFE AND I CAN SEE BOTH OUR KIDS
WITH.
AND WE KNEW WE WOULD BOTH BE ON
THE PERSON.
WE THOUGHT THAT MEANT THAT WE
WOULD BE PRETTY
DAD BUT LEGALLY BY.
WE FOUND OUT WHEN I WAS
PREGNANT WITH HENRIETTA ACTUALLY
NO.
WE WANT PROTECT ED AND WE HAVE
TO ADOPT HER OWN KIDS.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE I WAS
SHOCKED HOW WAS THAT BAD I COULD
BE THERE FROM BEFORE BOTH OF OUR
KIDS ARE CONCEIVED.
AND BEYOND THE PER CERTIFICATE
AND AND STILL HAVE TO ADOPT BOTH
OF OUR OWN KIDS AND THEY'LL
HAVE.
IT WAS IT WAS AWFUL. AND IT
INVOLVED TIME MONEY GATHERING
DOCUMENTS AND FILLING OUT MANY
FORMS OF ARE TURNING.
THE LOWEST MOMENT FOR ME WAS
WHEN I HAD TO LIST MYSELF AS A
STEP PARENT TO MY OWN KID. YEAH
I MEAN HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE.
I WOULDN'T KNOW I GUESS I WAS
THERE FROM THE BEGINNING AND IT
WAS JUST.
.
IT SHOULD HAVE WHAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A TIME OF JOY AND
EXCITEMENT TURNS INTO A TIME OF.
STRAUSS AND YOU KNOW NOT BEING
SURE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN TO ME
DURING CHILDBIRTH CELL.
I'M IN THE FACT THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY FINISHED THE ADOPTION
WITH HENRY UNTIL AFTER HE WAS
BORN WAS ALSO REALLY.
REALLY STRESSFUL.
AND AWFUL TO GO THROUGH.
SO. I'M.
IT WOULD HAVE MADE SUCH A
DIFFERENCE OF THERE BEEN A
FORUM.
THAT WE COULD FIND RIGHT THERE
IN THE HOSPITAL AFTER BOTH OF
OUR KIDS BIRTH.
THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN US THE
ADDED LEGAL SECURITY RIGHT THEN
AND THERE.
I THINK ABOUT THE HEAVY
FINANCIAL OPERATIONAL AND
EMOTIONAL IMPACT JUMPING THROUGH
ALL OF THESE HOOPS HAD ON ME AND
MY FAMILY.
AND THEN I THINK OF ALL THE POOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS WITHOUT ALL THE PRIVILEGES
THAT WE HAVE AND IT BREAKS MY
AB TWO SIX EIGHT POOR WOULD
PROFOUNDLY AND POSITIVELY IMPACT
LEGAL PROTECTIONS AND INCLUSIONS
REQUIRE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWO SIX
REPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND MR GOING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE.
I MEAN HOUSE YES.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
RICHARD POPPIN ON BEHALF OF THEY
MAKE THE BAY AREA MUNICIPAL
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TURN MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO INSPIRED.
JIM WHEN BERDYCH ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS.
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LOOK MANY MEMBERS MY NAME STUDIO
PAL AND I'M A BERKELEY SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND THE LESBIAN MOM
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REVEREND DR PAMELA ANDERSON
MODERATOR OF THE SACRAMENTO
PRESBYTERY I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
GEORGE RYAN BOARD OF THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY CENTER
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE A BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THE MOTION AND THEY SECONDS.
ALTHOUGH YOU MAY CLOSE OR HENRY
NICKLE.
EVEN IF THE PLAY THANK.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE
FACT THAT I HAVE SHAMELESSLY
BROUGHT NOT ONE BUT TWO BABIES
HERE TO HELP BUT CONVINCE YOU OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL. I
KNOW THAT.
I HAD AN INFLUENCE ON LEAST AT
AT LEAST ONE. PERSON WHO WAS ON
THE DIETS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
CHOW. CHOW I CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU GET. RIGHT MISTER
CUNNINGHAM AND MISTER GARCIA.
THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TO OPEN THREE
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MORNING.
.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN I'M.
WITH ME AT THE TABLE IS MY JOINT
AUTHORS SOME WOMEN. GARCIA AND
YOU WILL. ALONZO GARZA WHO IS
THE FOUNDER OF THE MOTHERS AND
MANIKINS GANGS COALITION.
LIKE TO START BY THANKING TO
COMMITTEE FOR THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WHICH WE WILL ACCEPT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE NAMES AND.
WELL THE NAMES OF VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES TO CRIME I CAN BE
ACCESS USING A PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST THE SOMETIMES IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES CAN
DISTURB DISCOURAGE COOPERATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
PROVIDE A MECHANISM?
BY WHICH THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
THE NAMES OF THE VICTIMS OF
WITNESSES TO CRIMES WHERE
THERE'S A REASON TO BELIEVE THEY
MAY BE IN DANGER.
CAN BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL.
OF THE BILL PASSED PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON A SIX ZERO VOTE I
BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED BY THIS COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN THE BILL.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
BUT.
THANK YOU THIS GARCIA I WILL BE
BRIEF UP MUCH CHAIR IN JANUARY
THAT THIS BODY TOOK UP ACR.
ONE THIRTY FOUR THAT DECLARED.
JANUARY IN CALIFORNIA'S GANG
AWARENESS
PREVENTION MONTH.
THIS A BILL I BELIEVE IS THE
COMMON SENSE BILL TO ENCOURAGE.
OF THOSE OF HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
BY.
GANGS AND OR ANY OTHER CRIMES
TO.
FEELS SECURE CONFIDENT.
UNCOMFORTABLE.
COMING FORWARD AND KNOWING THAT
THE. LAW IS ON THEIR SIDE TO
PROTECT THEM.
SO.
WITH US TODAY IS A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR MARK DISTRICT.
YOU LEAD.
ALONSO GARZA WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE.
MOTHERS AND MEN AGAINST THAT
GANGS A COALITION IMPROVE COUNTY
WHO MANY OF YOU ARE CUT TO MEET
THE DAY THAT WE PRESENT THE
RESOLUTION. AND THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALL YOUR
EYEBALLS.
THANK YOU WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN.
VICE CHAIRMAN.
IT'S VERY COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS SHEILA ALSO GARCIA I
AM THE MOTHER OF MY THEME A
VECTOR GARCIA A VICTIM OF GANG.
VIOLENCE AN INNOCENT VICTIM. I'M
ALSO A TEACHER OF MANY STUDENTS.
WHO OFTEN BECOME VICTIMS?
I AM ALSO A CATALYST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
TWO ENSURE SAFETY IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AS A FOLLOWUP TO ACR ONE THIRTY
FOUR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN BROUGHT TO YOU BY.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISTER LAVA
GARCIA.
THIS WEEK.
NATIONALLY WE RECOGNIZE.
CRIME VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK.
AND IT'S ALL VICTIMS.
AND.
ARE THE SEVEN DAYS TODAY'S A
THIRD DAY.
AND SEVEN THREE IS A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER BECAUSE SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK.
MY COALITION.
FAMILIES OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THOSE THAT ARE IN CHARGE OF
THE LAWS THAT PROTECT US.
WORK TOGETHER SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
TO ENSURE THAT OUR FUTURES ARE
BRIGHT.
I STARTED MY MORNING.
AT TWELVE AM.
TRAVELING FROM. IMPERIAL COUNTY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND IT'S NOT
JUST IMPORTANT FOR MY SON WHOM.
WE DID GET JUSTICE FOR.
IN ORDER TO GET JUSTICE I
ACTUALLY STARTED A CAMPAIGN.
TO GET JUSTICE FOR MARTINEZ BUT
BUT PARTS OF MY SON AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
BECAUSE I HAD PREVIOUSLY SEEN.
THE PERPETRATOR GET AWAY WITH
MANY CRIMES
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LACK OF
WITNESSES.
AND DO TO THE FACT THAT THERE
WAS A LACK OF WITNESSES
HE WAS RELEASED.
ON AN ATTEMPTED MURDER
CHARGE ON THURSDAY.
AND MURDERED OUR SON.
ON SATURDAY.
THE PERPETRATORS.
YOUTH SIGNIFICANT.
WAYS.
TO HINDER.
A COMMUNITY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T
OVERCOME.
CRIME THAT IS COMMITTED TO THEM.
MANY OF THEM HIDE. WHICH WAS THE
CASE FOR ONE OF OUR WITNESSES.
HE HAD A HAND.
SKIP DOT ON A LOTTA BENCH
WARRANTS.
UNTIL THE JUDGE FINALLY PUT HIM
IN JAIL.
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN IN JAIL.
OUR WITNESS WAS NOT SAFE.
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN HIT PUT ON
HIM BY THE LOCAL GANGS. BECAUSE
HE WAS GOING TO TESTIFY.
THERE ARE SO MANY CASES LIKE
THIS.
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND TODAY I AM HERE. TO VOICE.
FOR THOSE THAT ARE VOICELESS.
A TEDDY BEAR.
IS WHAT I USED TO SIGNIFY.
AND TO SYMBOLIZE MY SON.
THE TROUBLE WITH HIM EVERYWHERE
I'VE LEFT HIM IN SEVERAL OFFICES
AND IF CAPITOL BUILDING.
WITH OUR GOVERNOR PUT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
WHAT THIRD ASSEMBLY SPEAKER?
WHAT PARRIS THUMPAMON?
THAT ARE HERE WITH ME TODAY.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL I HAVE. AFTER
HE WAS VIOLENTLY TAKEN FROM US.
I ALSO HAVE A REPRESENTATION OF
A PARENTS OF MURDERED CHILDREN.
CHILD.
ANOTHER REPRESENTATION POT.
SIGNIFIES THERE'S ANOTHER
VICTIM.
A VIOLENT.
BECAUSE.
THEIR PERPETRATORS THAT WILL
REPEAT THEIR CRIMES.
AND THE SPECIAL PERSON
WITH GIVEN TIMMY BY A
GRANDMOTHER.
OF A VICTIM THAT HAS A NON SOLVE
CASE IN OUR COUNTY.
AND I TOLD HER THAT I WOULD PUT
MY PURSE DOWN. TODAY.
TO ENSURE THAT I ALONG WITH ALL
OF YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE AND OUR
ASSEMBLYMAN WHO ARE. TAKING THE
LEAD ON THIS.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE SAFE.
THE DAY I BROUGHT MY SON'S
JACKET BECAUSE I WANTED TO
DEMONSTRATE SOMETHING THAT HE
LEFT.
WHICH WAS THE FAINT.
PUT HER PURSE DOWN FUND.
THE MEANING BE FINE BEHIND THAT
IS.
TO NOT LET FEAR INTIMIDATION.
HINDER YOUR DREAMS.
OR YOUR GOALS.
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR PURSE DOWN
AND YOU HAVE TO STEP UP EVEN IF
YOU'RE STANDING ALONE.
THREE OUT OF EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU.
TO NOT ONLY BE THE VOICE FOR MY
SON.
BUT BICU THE VOICE FOR FUTURE
VICTIMS.
I'M BE THE VOICE FOR THOSE
WITNESSES THAT CAN GIVE OF
CLOSURE OF PARENTS OF MURDERED
CHILDREN. OF
ALL VICTIMS OF CRIME.
I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE.
SUPPORT.
ASSEMBLYMAN CUNNINGHAM AND
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA ON AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE YEAR THAT OUR SON
WAS VIOLENTLY TAKEN FROM US.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT YOU COULD GIVE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISS CHAIR RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SECOND YOU MAKE ROOM FOR THE
OPPOSITION AT THE TABLE.
MY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KEVIN BAKER PROTECT CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION THAT'S
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL AS
IT'S
OPPOSED TO BE AMENDED SINCE WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THE LANGUAGE OF
THAT. THOSE AMENDMENTS
I'M SO AND I CAN ONLY SPEAK
GENERALLY TO THE ISSUE HARM.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PAIN IN THE
TRAGEDY HAVE EXPERIENCED BY THE
WITNESS I THINK WE ALL HAVE.
GREAT APPRECIATION
FOR FOUND THAT SITUATION I THINK
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER ON
CUTTING BACK ON THE SCOPE OF THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT IN SOME WAY.
IS GOING TO BELIEVER AVOID THAT.
THAT KIND.
AND I'M I'M I'M NOT AT ALL SURE
THAT THAT IT WOULD COME IN THE
LAST WEEK I WOULD LIKE TO REVIEW
THE AMENDMENTS WHEN THEY'RE.
IN PRINT AND WILL.
TECHNO LOOK AT THE BILL AT THAT
TIME.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM YOU WORK WITH A
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
A WE ALSO SYMPATHIZE WITH.
VICTIMS OF A VIOLENT CRIME IN A
GANG ACTIVITY.
.
BUT ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT WAS
CREATED WITH A PRESUMPTION OF
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
ABOUT WITNESSES AND VICTIMS.
IN ORDER FOR THE COMMUNITY
ITSELF TO UNDERSTAND THE NATURE
OF CRIME ARE IN IT IN THE AREA
WHERE. PEOPLE LIVE
ON AND ALSO TO HELP PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THAT CRIME.
AND ANY DIMINISHMENT OF ACCESS
TO THAT INFORMATION.
DISABLED PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE
TO DO THAT.
AND WHAT WE WOULD NEVER SUGGEST
THAT PUBLIC ACCESS SHOULD ALWAYS
TRUMP.
THE PERSONAL SAFETY OF SOMEONE
WHO WAS A VICTIM OR WITNESS.
THE LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS WHO FOR
AMECHANISM TO BE USED WHEN
THERE IS A THREAT TO A VICTIM A
WITNESS OR THE INVESTIGATION
ITSELF WE THINK THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE STANDARD AND. IF
THERE IS ANYONE ANYWHERE WHERE
REFORM.
SHOULD BE FOCUSED IT IS ON THAT
WHERE IT MAY BE DEFECTIVE OR
INADEQUATE IN PROTECTING.
OF VICTIMS OR WITNESSES WE THINK
THAT THAT IS WHERE.
THE FOCUS SHOULD BE.
I'M WITH RESPECT TO THE
AMENDMENT WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
LANGUAGE EITHER.
UP BASED ON THE DESCRIPTION IN
THE ANALYSIS.
WERE CONCERNED THAT IT MIGHT
EXTEND AND GO BROADER THAN THAT
WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN THE BILL
NOW. ALLOWING FOR ANYONE
INVOLVED IN INVESTIGATION TO
MAKE THE REQUEST.
UP BUT AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THAT YET AND.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE LANGUAGE
BEFORE.
TAKING POSITIONS.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION NO
WITH CONCERNS.
SEE NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND.
I AGREE THAT WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH PUBLIC RECORDS PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT IS BUT THERE FOR A
VERY SPECIFIC REASON.
BUT AS WE'VE SEEN THROUGH.
HISTORY OUT OF THIS HOUSE AND
AND OTHERS THERE THERE ARE TIMES
WHERE WE CAN WE NEED TO BE MORE
PROTECTIVE LESS PROTECTIVE AND
SO THESE CONVERSATIONS.
TRY TO FIND A BALANCE BETWEEN
WHAT THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY IN OUR
SOCIETY. SARRIS ACT
YEAH AGAINST TRYING TO PROTECT
FOLKS IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE.
SO WILL WILL STAY IN TOUCH WITH
RESPECT TO THE MEMBERS THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING WE'RE TRYING
THAT. HELP FACILITATE SOME OF
THAT BALANCE HERE SO THAT WE
DON'T FRUSTRATE THE PURPOSES OF
WHAT THE AUTHORS ARE INTENDING.
BUT BUT ALSO NOT UNNECESSARILY.
LIMIT ACCESS.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SETTLEMENT.
TO MAKE LOVE SUDDEN MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD JUST CLOSE BY SAYING I
DO BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDED
BILL.
STRIKES THE PROPER BALANCE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIDE.
THANK YOU SECRECY.
RIGHT.
SO STILL LOOKING FOR A MOTION
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROACH.
WE DO HAVE NO EMOTION AND THE
SECONDS.
THANK YOU KALRA PLEASE STONE BY
STONE I CUNNINGHAM FIGHT
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
SHALL I CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
HICKMAN DO VERY MUCH.
THAT BRINGS US UP TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE
MISTER LOW
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FORTY
THREE.
TO CLARIFY THAT CONVERSION
THERAPY IS THAT FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE UNDER THE CONSUMER
LEGAL REMEDIES ACT.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THIS BILL THAT AS YOU
HAVE SEEN IN THE ANALYSIS AND AS
WELL STATED AND WELL KNOWN. OF
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES.
WITH RESPECT TO SOMETHING LIKE
CONVERSION THERAPY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD ARTICULATE AND
ARGUE WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU
AFFECT THE AMERICAN PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION THE
AMERICAN COUNSELING ASSOCIATION
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION. OF
SOCIAL WORKERS THEY AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALL ALSO
BELIEVE THAT CONVERSION THERAPY
A DOES NOT WORK AND THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO IT'S IS IT SUGGESTS
THAT IT DOES WORK AND IN FACT IT
DOES. SIGNIFICANT HARM TO ONCE
MENTAL HEALTH.
THIS BILL WOULD NARROWLY APPLY
IN CASES WHERE CONSUMER
TRANSACTION HAS TAKEN PLACE.
AND.
WITH ME TODAY ARE DOCTOR DOUG
HOW THE MEN FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION.
SAM BRITAIN A SURVIVOR OF
CONVERSION THERAPY.
MATTHEW SUREKHA SURVIVOR OF
CONSERVATIVE CONVERSION THERAPY
AND ANTHONY SAMPSON.
I ALSO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
BUTTON WITH RESPECT ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR DOUG HALDEMAN
I AM THE IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
PROFESSOR AND CHAIR OF THE
DOCTORAL PROGRAM IN CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGY. AT JOHN F. KENNEDY
UNIVERSITY IN PLEASANT HILL THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN AGREEMENT WITH
EVERY MAJOR HEALTH CARE
ORGANIZATION IN THE UNITED
STATES. BELIEVES THAT THERE IS
NO BASIS FOR ATTEMPTING TO
CHANGE SEXUAL ORIENTATION FOR
SEVERAL REASONS
FIRST SAME SEX ATTRACTIONS AND
BEHAVIORS ARE A NORMATIVE ASPECT
OF THE HUMAN EXPERIENCE AND NOT
A FORM OF MENTAL ILLNESS
REQUIRING. TREATMENT.
TWO THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
SUPPORTING EFFORTS TO CHANGE
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AS SHOWN BY
AN EXTENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE. BY THE
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION THREE THESE METHODS
POSE A SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF HARM
TO THE INDIVIDUAL AND LASTLY
THERE ARE NUMEROUS OTHER
THERAPEUTICALLY LEGITIMATE
METHODS FOR ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS. OF PERSONS WHO ARE
QUESTIONING OR CONFUSED ABOUT
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION WITHOUT
RESORTING TO CONVERSION THERAPY.
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS I HAVE
CONDUCTED RESEARCH WRITTEN
ORGANIZATIONAL POLICY AND
MAINTAINED A CLINICAL PRACTICE
THAT INCLUDED HUNDREDS OF BOYS
AND MEN WHO HAD UNDERGONE. SOME
FORM OF SO CALLED CONVERSION
THERAPY INCLUDING AVERSIVE
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS GENITAL
ELECTRIC SHOCK AND NAUSEA AND
DO.
DRUGS A VARIETY OF BEHAVIORAL
METHODS RESIDENTIAL TREATMENTS
INVOLVING FORCED ISOLATION AND
SO FORTH.
CONSISTENT WITH THE LACK OF
EMPIRICAL SUPPORT FOR CONVERSION
TREATMENTS NONE OF THESE METHODS
WAS EFFECTIVE IT CHANGING ONES
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND USUALLY
EXACERBATED THE PERSON'S ALREADY
SUBSTANTIAL GUILT. AND SELF
LOATHING.
MANY OF THESE PATIENTS REPORTED
THAT THEIR CONVERSION THERAPISTS
HAD LIED TO THEM ABOUT SAME SEX
ATTRACTIONS WHO TOLD THEM THAT
THERE QUOTE GAY MENTAL ILLNESS
WAS THE RESULT OF EARLY LIKE
SEXUAL TRAUMA. OR BLAME TO THEM
FOR NOT TRYING HARD ENOUGH
NGUYEN CONVERSION THERAPY.
THERAPY ULTIMATELY FAILED THEM.
MANY REPORTED THAT THEIR
CONVERSION THERAPISTS ADMONISHED
THEM TO CHANGE THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BECAUSE GAY PEOPLE'S
LIVES ARE INVARIABLY MISERABLE
DEVOID OF PRODUCTIVITY MEANING
OR FULFILLING RELATIONSHIPS.
IF THESE KINDS OF MESSAGES ARE
THERE FREE SPEECH THAT
CONVERSION THERAPIST SEEK THEY
WOULD DO WELL TO READ OUR CODE
OF ETHICS WHICH PROHIBITS THE
WILLFUL DISSEMINATION. OF
INACCURATE STATEMENTS IN THE
SERVICE OF PROMOTING THE METHODS
AND MANIPULATING CLIENTS.
AFTER DECADES OF WORKING WITH
SURVIVORS OF CONVERSION THERAPY
I'M ABSOLUTELY CONVINCED THAT
THESE TREATMENTS HOLD OUT FALSE
HOPE TO THOSE WHO ARE DEALING
WITH CONFLICT ABOUT THEIR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION DERIVED. FROM A
HOMOPHOBIC SOCIAL WORLD. THESE
METHODS DON'T WORK AND POSE
SUBSTANTIAL RISK TO THE
INDIVIDUAL.
ACCORDINGLY
CPA BELIEVES THAT IT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF THE STATE.
IT IS ACTUALLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE TO
ACCURATELY IDENTIFY THESE
PRACTICES AS CONSUMER FRAUD.
PLACING SUCH ACTIVITIES ARE TO
THE CONSUMER IS.
BUT LEGAL REMEDIES ACT SERVES TO
PUT THE PURVEYORS OF CONVERSION
THERAPIES ON NOTICE THAT THEY
CAN NO LONGER GET AWAY WITH
THESE PRACTICES AND SENDS A
MESSAGE TO LGBT AND QUESTIONING
PERSON OF ALL AGES. THAT THERE
IS NOTHING WRONG WITH YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US.
SURE STONE AND FELLOW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY THOUGHTS
ON THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
THE TREVOR PROJECT IS PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR A BETWEEN I'M FORTY
THREE WHICH AT THAT CODIFY THAT
MAKES IT SPLIT IN CALIFORNIA
LAW.
THAT EFFORTS TO CHANGE PERSON
FEATURING TATIAN. ARE THE
FRAUDULENT BUSINESS PRACTICE
UNDER THE CONSUMER LEGAL
REMEDIES ACT. AS THE LEADING
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FIGHTING
CRISIS INTERVENTION AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION SERVICES FOR LGBTQ
YOUTH THE TREVOR PROJECT. URGES
THE SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT THE ULTRA COMMUNITY FROM
CONVERSION THERAPY.
CONVERSION THERAPIES THERAPISTS
USE ME FALSELY CLAIM TO BE ABLE
TO CHANGE US INTO STRAIGHT AND
THIS GENDER PEOPLE PROMINENT
HEALTH ASSOCIATIONS INCLUDING
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS. OPPOSE
THE USE OF CONVERSION THERAPY
CALLING THE PRACTICE HARMFUL AND
INEFFECTIVE.
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA'S LEAD ONLY
ELEVEN STATES TOTAL HAVE PASSED
LEGISLATION LIMITING THE A
PRACTICE ON YOUTH THOUGH ANOTHER
THIRTY NINE STATES STILL ALLOW
THIS TERRIBLE CRISIS TO
CONTINUE.
OUR DRIVER PROJECTS LIFELINE
FREQUENTLY RECEIVES CALLS OF
LGBTQ YOUTH IN CRISIS
STEMMING FROM THEIR EXPERIENCES
IN CONVERSION THERAPY AND AIMS
ADVOCATE PREVENTS WILL END OF
THE STATE THING XIN CONVERSION
THERAPY. THERAPY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY VIA OUR FIFTY BILL FIFTY
STATE CAMPAIGN.
I'M A SURVIVOR OF CONVERSION
THERAPY.
THE DANGEROUS DISCREDITED
FRAUDULENT IDEA THE THERAPIST
COULD CHANGE MY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR MY GENDER
IDENTITY ALTHOUGH SOME MAY SAY
THE CONVERSION THERAPY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED OF THE CHOICE.
I SIMPLY REPLY THAT I NEVER
CHOSE THE THERAPY MY.
MY FAMILY SUBJECTED ME TO DURING
MY FORMATIVE YEARS OF THE CHILD.
MY EXPERIENCE OF THE INVERSION
THERAPY RANGE FROM TALKING ABOUT
LIKE BEATS REJECTION OF MY
BISEXUALITY ALL THE WAY TO
PHYSICALLY AVERSIVE THAT
TECHNIQUES. LIKE THE APPLICATION
OF HEAT ICE AND ELECTRICITY TO
MY BODY TO FORCIBLY TRAIN ME TO
HAVE HETEROSEXUAL ATTRACTION.
TO RESPOND TO THE PAINFUL YEARS
I NOW SERVE AS THE COACH OF THE
BORN PERMITTED BY THE COMMITTEE
AND THE HEAD OF ADVOCACY IN
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
TREVOR PROJECT. YOU'VE CALL
THINK CRISIS AND SUICIDE NEEDING
SOMEONE TO SPEAK TO WHEN THEY
FEEL ALONE AND SCARED NOT ALL
THESE YOU FOR VICTIMS OF
CONVERSION THERAPY BUT ALL HAVE
BEEN WOUNDED BY A CULTURE. THAT
ALLOWS THE FALSE IDEA OF THE
CHOICE OF ONE FACTUAL LIGHT
ORIENTATION TO PERMIT VIOLENCE
BULLYING AND FAMILY REJECTION IN
OUR RESEARCH WITH THE BILLIONS
INSTITUTE WE NOW I THINK THAT
ESTIMATE THAT SEVEN HUNDRED.
THOUSAND LGBTQ PEOPLE HAVE
EXPERIENCED CONVERSION THERAPY.
EIGHTY THOUSAND YOUTH ARE STILL
AT RISK OF CONVERSION THERAPY IN
THE COMING YEARS.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO STOP
THAT NUMBER FROM CONTINUING TO
GROW.
CONVERSION THERAPY DOES NOT HAVE
A SCIENTIFIC STANDING THEY ARE
STEALING FROM HARD WORKING
AMERICAN FAMILIES WERE BEING
SWINDLED WHILE TRYING TO HAVE
THE BEST INTEREST OF THEIR
CHILDREN AT HEART.
THIS IS CONSUMER FRAUD AND
COURTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
AGREED ON THIS POINT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN BY NOTIFYING THE
SNAKE OIL SALESMAN THAT PEDAL
CONVERSION THERAPY TO
UNSUSPECTING PARENTS.
THAT THEIR PRACTICE VIOLATES CUT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAWS
IF LEGISLATION WHAT CAUGHT MY
PROTECTION THINK OF THE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
THEY CAN'T CHANGE WHAT WE NEVER
CHOSE.
THANK YOU.
EXPLICITLY.
ARMENIANS MATTHEW SUREKHA I
AIMED AT ME CONVERSION THERAPY
SURVIVOR MEANING I HAD GONE
THROUGH THE THERAPY AND I'M AN
OUT GAY MAN TODAY. MUSCLE LEAD
ADVOCATE FOR THE POOR PERFECT
CAMPAIGN AND ON THE.
ADVISER ABOUT THE COMMITTEE FOR
ME ADVISER ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
BOARD PREDICTS.
AND.
.
I WAS PRETTY CONVERSION THEIR
BEAT EACH SIXTEEN WHEN I CAME
OUT TO MY PARENTS I WAS TREATED
IN FOUR DIFFERENT STATES ARM
SPECIFICALLY WAS TREATED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWO YEARS.
ARMED.
I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON
THE FRAUDULENT PART BUT IN TOTAL
I WAS.
THE CONVERSION EVERY FROM AGE
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY ONE FOR FIVE
YEARS TWO BY FOUR DIFFERENT
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS.
MY PARENTS SPENT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON MY
CONVERSION THERAPY.
WHAT I WAS TOLD MY FIRST BEGAN
CONVERSION THERAPY WAS THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD
AND I HAD ENGAGE IN SAME SEX
INTERCOURSE THAT I PROBABLY
WOULD BE? SEE MY OPPOSITE SEX
ATTRACTION COME BACK WITHIN SIX
WEEKS.
WHEN THAT DIDN'T WORK. LIKE
BEYOND THE JOHN HERE SAID.
THE BLAME IS ON ME BECAUSE I
WANT TO NOT TRY HARD ENOUGH.
OREGON UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
TRUMP WAS WHAT CAUSED NAM
SEXUALITY.
SO I MENTALLY BEGAN.
ATTORNEY ON TRY TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE MY HOMOSEXUALITY CAME FROM
USUALLY AT THE BLAME A PARENT OR
AN INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED IN
CHILDHOOD.
LUCKY FOR ME I WAS I COME FROM A
LOVING FAMILY A GROUP IN A
CONSERVATIVE HOME WHERE MY
PARENTS.
I WOULD SAY THAT A GREAT JOB.
BOB AND RELAXING NOTHING
SPECIFIC I COULD ACTUALLY
DISCOVER.
BOB BECAUSE I KNEW OF MY
SEXUALITY WASN'T EVER CHANGING.
MY DEPRESSION GREW OF THE FEARS
OF WHAT IT IS TO COME OUT AS A
GAY MAN BASED ON WHAT MY FATHER
FEARED ABOVE MY CONVERSION
THERAPIST FEARED.
MY DEPRESSION A INCREASED AND I
CONTEMPLATED
A POSSIBLE SUICIDE FOR FOR TWO
YEARS.
A PART OF THE THERAPY WAS ALSO
TWO SEPARATE FROM AL FEMALES I
HAD TO GO THROUGH A DEFECT IN
NUYS EIGHT. D. FEMINIZED PROCESS
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY RULES
WITH MALES AND FEMALES AND
ESSENTIALLY DO NOT SPEAK TO MY
MOTHER TO SUGGEST FOR THREE
YEARS.
WITH ALL THAT SAID AND DONE AND
THAT IS THE EXPERIENCE OF IT.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY IS HOW
CONVERSION THERAPIES ROUND AS A
BUSINESS
MY PARENTS SPENT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS?
AND WHAT WAS.
THE WORDS ARE BEING USED THERE'S
REPAIRED IF THEY'RE BEING
CONVERSION THERAPY
WHICH ARE INTERCHANGEABLE AND
WE'D REALLY DISCUSS THIS TOPIC
AS ANYONE WHO'S ATTEMPTING TO
CHANGE SOMEONE'S SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
PREPARED IF THERE BE IS
ATTORNEY BEEN USED A LOT IN.
IT THE LAST FEW DECADES ARMED IN
MA'AM I MEAN JUST BECAUSE YOU
SENIOR WHO PASSED AWAY AT LEAST
LATE LAST EARLY LAST YEAR. AND
THE SON OF JUST INEQUALITY
JUNIOR NAM IS CONTINUING THE
BUSINESS AND HAS TWO NEW OFFICES
ONE IN MANHATTAN AND ONE IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA.
HE IS OUR RECENTLY TRADEMARKED.
REPAIRED IF THERE BE AND THAT'S
WITH THE U. S. TPO.
THAT'S A GREAT CONCERN BECAUSE
IT'S NO LONGER JUST DESCRIBED AS
A THERAPY BUT DESCRIBE THE
PRODUCTS THAT IT IS FOR SALE.
.
OF COURSE MY PARENTS AGUIAR WITH
WHAT TOM.
PEEL LIKE A PROFESSIONAL TO
TREAT ME ARM BUT.
OBVIOUSLY I'M THEY ALMOST LOST
ME IF I COMMITTED SUICIDE I LOST
MY MOTHER FOR THREE YEARS WITH
THE STRAIN FOR MY ENTIRE FAMILY
FOR TOTAL FIVE.
AND LIKELY TO REBUILD THAT.
BUT JUST SO WE UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING A MEDICAL
ORGANIZATION HAS DENOUNCED
CONVERSION OR PREPARED IF
THERE'D BE.
PREPARED IF THERE BE SIR I NEED
YOU TO WRAP UP THIS YEAR.
IN AND OF ITSELF IS SAYING THAT
THERE'S IT'S GOING AGAINST
WHAT THE MEDICAL PROCEDURE
SAYING THAT BECAUSE IT WOULD
REPAIRS ANY. IT'S FRAUDULENT
FROM BEFORE EVEN BEGAN BECAUSE
IT'S SAYING THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED
WHICH IS. ANYTHING OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. ARM I PREACH YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF THE
BILL I'M IN SUPPORT OF.
THANKYOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
JOHN MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND OUR PROGRAM CALIFORNIA FAITH
FOR EQUALITY WE ARE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PRITCHARD PAPEN ON BEHALF OF
THEY MAKE THE BAY AREA MUNICIPAL
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALICE KESSLER OF BEEN ASKED BY
LAMBDA LEGAL TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THINK YOU.
EMILY WARD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FAN PULLOUT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
JUDY APPEL BERKLEE SCHOOL BOARD
OUT LESBIAN AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
WILLIAM WATSON BURGER BEHALF OF
OUR POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AUSTRALIS AIR ON BEHALF OF THE
ALICE B. TOKLAS DEMOCRATIC CLUB
STRONG SUPPORT.
JERRY PAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
REVEREND DR PAMELA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENT OF
PRESBYTERY AS MODERATOR I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HOLY MICHON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE POINT REPRESENTING AMERICAN
CAN READ PAEDIATRICS FIVE
THOUSAND.
SOME SPECIALISTS AS WELL AS
BOARD CERTIFIED PEDIATRICIANS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN SUPPORT.
CUT THE MUSTARD REFUSING THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
CHECK OUT CAN YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BE OF ALL HEALTH AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MENTALLY MY PERSONAL CAPACITY AS
BOARD PRESIDENT QUALITY
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT.
CARLOS MARQUEZ ON BEHALF THAT.
SEGMENT LJUBISA COMMUNITY
CENTER AND THAT CALTRAIN CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LOGAN WOLVERTON AND SHAUN
SACRAMENTO STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC
CLUB STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM LIMBURGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE QUAKER BASED
OUT LOBBY PUBLIC INTEREST GROUP
AND SUPPORT BACK.
CALIFORNIANS FOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
TO THE TABLE
.
MORNING.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS KEVIN SNYDER WITH PACIFIC
JUSTICE INSTITUTE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC POLICY WHERE SERVICE
CHIEF COUNSEL.
I DRESSED BRIEFLY THE LEGAL
DISCUSSION IN THE BILL'S
ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL DIFFERS SIGNIFICANTLY
FROM THE LAW BANNING SEXUAL
ORIENTATION CHANGE EFFORTS OR
SOCIAL FOR THOSE UNDER EIGHTEEN.
TWO CASES CHALLENGED THAT LAW
UNDER FREE SPEECH AND FREE
EXERCISE OF RELIGION IN PICK UP
VERSES BROWN AND PICK AND WELSH
FORCES BROWN. THE COURT HELD
THAT A PROHIBITION ON SO SHHH.
PERSONS UNDER EIGHTEEN SURVIVED
TO THESE CHALLENGES BECAUSE THE
LAW WAS NARROWLY FOCUSED ON THE
REGULATION OF PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT.
BUT THE NINTH CIRCUIT FOUND THAT
EVEN LICENSED PROFESSIONALS
COULD COMMUNICATE WITH THE
PUBLIC ABOUT SOCIAL.
IN CONTRAST
THIS BILL PROHIBITS SOCIAL
ADVERTISEMENTS
BY ALL PERSONS.
FURTHER THE COURT FOUND THAT
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS COULD
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND SOCIAL TO
PATIENTS AND COULD ADMINISTER
SOCIAL TO ADULTS AND REFER
MINERS TO UNLICENSED COUNSELORS
OR RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
GET UNDER THIS BILL ALL OF THOSE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE SWEPT
AWAY.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE IS
NOT A REGULATION OF PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT RATHER THAN THE BUSINESS
AND
PROFESSIONS CODE.
UNLIKE THE PREVIOUS LAW THIS
BILL STRETCHES FAR BEYOND
LICENSE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
IT REACHES OF RELIGIOUS
MINISTRIES ENGAGED IN SOCIAL. IF
THERE IS AN EXCHANGE OF MONEY
FOR EXAMPLE PAIN FOR A RELIGIOUS
RETREAT A WORKBOOK OR SEMINAR.
I DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO WHAT
THIS LOOKS LIKE AN AND NOT IN
ANOTHER STATE.
TWO MONTHS AGO A CHURCH PUT ON A
SEMINAR THAT DEALT WITH THIS
VERY ISSUE THIS HAPPENED IN
MICHIGAN.
FIVE STATE LAWMAKERS URGE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO INVESTIGATE
AND FILE AN INJUNCTION AGAINST
THE CHURCH FOR VIOLATION. FOR
VIOLATING THE COULD MICHIGAN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ACT.
CHAIRMAN I URGE THAT THE MEMBERS
OF OF THIS BODY CAST A NO VOTE.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
DELIBERATION AND FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY.
THANK.
THAT'S WHAT.
I THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR
YOUR TIME.
MY NAME IS KEN WILLIAMS AND I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
LGBTQ PEOPLE TO HAVE ANY RIGHTS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM I BELIEVE
THEY DESERVE EVERY OPTION TO
PURSUE HAPPINESS THE WAY THEY
DETERMINE IT.
AND THIS BILL WHICH ARE TO
PROTECT THEM I BELIEVE WE'RE
ACTUALLY RIPPED AWAY SOME ENELE
INALIENABLE RIGHTS.
TO PURSUE HAPPINESS.
I WAS CONFUSED ABOUT MY GENDER
LIKE THAT LIKE THE GENTLEMAN.
MENTION BEFORE THAT THEY HAD.
SOME CONFUSION AND AND WHERE ON
A JOURNEY TO FIND THEMSELVES
SEXUALLY I CAN RELATE TO THEM
AND. AND I CAN FEEL THAT PAIN.
I DIDN'T FIT IN WITH THE BOYS
OR THE GIRLS EVER IN MY
CHILDHOOD.
AND ONE MY SEXUAL DESIRES EMERGE
THEY WERE ONLY FOR MEN.
AND THAT WAS REALLY DEVASTATING
FOR ME IT WAS VERY CONFUSING.
AND THAT AT SEVENTEEN I WAS I
CRASHED EMOTIONALLY AND I WAS.
TENTH CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE ON A
ON A DAILY BASIS FOR A LONG
TIME.
I TOLD MY PARENTS FINALLY I
BROKE DOWN WE CRIED TOGETHER
THEY SAID THEY LOVE ME NO MATTER
WHAT. AND THEY ASKED ME HOW THEY
COULD HELP.
WE FOUND A THERAPIST WHO WOULD
HELP ME PURSUE MIGHT MY OPTION.
AT WHICH I'M I WANTED CHANGE I
WANTED TO LIVE AS A MAN
HETEROSEXUALLY.
AND I DEVOURED THE FEW BOOKS AND
RESOURCES THAT WERE AVAILABLE I
DEVOURED THEM AND I JOINED A
GROUP.
AND SOME OF US EXPERIENCE THE
CHANGES THAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
IN THAT GROUP NOT EVERYONE DID.
DESPITE YEARS OF HOMOSEXUAL
IDENTITY AND BEHAVIOR MY SEXUAL
DESIRES THAT DID CHANGE.
I'M NO LONGER SEXUALLY ATTRACTED
TO MEN.
AND I I IN MEDI GIRL AND. DON'T
LOVE WITH HER.
WAS SEXUALLY AROUSED BY HER AND
I MARRIED HER IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX.
SHE'S THE ONE PERSON WHO THROWS
ME SEXUALLY. I'M FAITHFUL TO HER
AND SHE WENT INTO HEART FAILURE.
AFTER DELIVERING MY TWINS.
AND I'M I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD
EVER SEE HER ALIVE AGAIN I READ
FOR IRAN FOR RED LIGHTS TRYING
TO GET TO HER HOPING I WOULD SEE
HER ALIVE AGAIN.
SHE'S THE WOMAN I LOVE AND
ASKING MY HELD HER HAND AS SHE
MISCARRIED OUR FIRST CHILD.
SHE IS MY MOST PRECIOUS GIFT.
AND TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE
WOULD HAVE STOLEN THIS RICH LIFE
FROM ME.
AND IT WOULD LEAVE THE MANY
OTHERS LIKE ME.
WHO ARE HURTING FINDING NO BOOKS
NO RESOURCES NO THERAPY?
UP SOME DO YOU WANT TO LIVE OUT
THEIR SAME SEX DESIRES AND THAT
IS THEIR RIGHT.
BUT NOT EVERYONE WHO FINDS
HIMSELF A SAME SEXES TIRES IS
WANTING. TO PURSUE THAT IS IS AT
PEACE WITH THAT.
AND SO I'M NOT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY ANYONE WOULD WANT
TO TAKE AWAY. THE RIGHTS ARE MY
PEOPLE GROUP WITCHES PEOPLE
FINDING THEMSELVES WITH THIS
IRISH THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE CHANGE.
PEOPLE'S BRAINS CAN CHANGE ITS
NEUROPLASTICITY.
AND WHY WOULD WE TELL PEOPLE
THAT THAT THERE WHY WOULD BY
WAITING UNTIL PEOPLE LIKE ME
THAT I DON'T EXIST OR THAT MY
DESIRE TO LIVE AUTHENTICALLY IS
FRAUDULENT.
WHAT RIGHT DOES GOVERNMENT HAVE
TO TELL ME HOW I HAVE TO
IDENTIFY SEXUALLY?
SO AYE OPPOSED AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY THREE BECAUSE I BELIEVE
IT'S A VIOLATION OF OUR FREE
SPEECH
AND ALSO PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH WANTING.
SIR I AM COMING UP AT THE LAST
MINUTE SOME SPEAKING TO YOU ALL
COMPLETELY SPONTANEOUSLY HAVEN'T
HAD ANY TIME TO PREPARE.
I'M I GREW UP BELIEVING THAT I
WAS.
WELL I WHAT DIDN'T FIT IN WITH
THE GIRLS I DIDN'T ACCEPT MY
LIFE IS A GIRL IDENTIFIED AS A
*.
I HAD MY FIRST RELATIONSHIP WITH
A WOMAN HE BEGAN SIXTEEN.
I CAME OUT IN MY EARLY TWENTIES
I LIVED LOCALLY HERE IN MIDTOWN
IN THE GAY COMMUNITY ALL THROUGH
MY TWENTIES.
I WANT TO SEMINARY IN A
PRESBYTERIAN SEMINARY IN CHICAGO
ILLINOIS. I'M OPENLY GAY I WAS
ONE OF MAYBE SIX WHO WERE OPENLY
OUT AND PROUD.
WHEN I GRADUATED FROM SEMINARY I
DID MINISTRY IN THE GAY
COMMUNITY.
BUT MY FACE JOURNEY LED ME OUT
OF THAT LIFESTYLE.
AS I PURSUED THE LORD I GAINED
FREEDOM EVENTUALLY GOT MARRIED
TO A MAN.
AND I DO MINISTRY AMONG OTHER
WOMEN WHO'VE HAD THE SAME
EXPERIENCE AS ME.
I'M I'M CONCERNED IS THAT THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH REFLECTIVE
SCIENTIFIC STUDY ON THE FLUIDITY
OF SEXUALITY FOR WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY.
AND THAT THIS BILL.
REALIZE THAT MANY WOMEN SEEK
REFUGE FROM MISOGYNY AND SEXISM
IN THE ARMS OF ANOTHER WOMAN.
AND THIS BILL COULD HINDER THAT
EXPERIENCE OF FREEDOM AND
HEALTH.
WHOLENESS TO WOMEN.
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS.
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
I'M MY NAME IS REYES SOLOMON
AND.
THIS BILL I OPPOSE BECAUSE IT'S
INTOLERANT.
OF MY RIGHT TO LIVE.
AS A EX GAY MAN.
A. AND ALSO IT TAKES AWAY MY
RIGHT TO THERAPY TO HAVE A FREE
PSYCHOLOGICAL SPACE.
IT'S NOT JUST CONVERSION
THERAPY THAT THIS BILL GOES
AGAINST IT GOES AGAINST ALL OF
THERAPY.
NOT REALLY IT RUINS THE THE.
.
THE THERAPEUTIC FRAME A HOME.
CLINICALLY SO THANK YOU.
CARL CALMLY WITH HIS MINISTRIES
IN FOLSOM.
AS A YOUNG MAN I STRUGGLE WITH
SAME SEX ATTRACTIONS AND THEY
WERE UNWANTED.
AND IT WAS THE RESOURCE OF THEIR
WOULD BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
THAT WERE VERY HELPFUL TO ME.
AND PUT ME ON A DIFFERENT
TRAJECTORY AND I'VE BEEN MARRIED
FOR FORTY YEARS AND GOT FOUR
CHILDREN VERY FULFILLED LIFE IN
NINETEEN NINETY A STARTED
MINISTRY. AT AND WE WEREN'T OUT
THERE ADVERTISING BUT I HAD I'VE
HAD OVER THE YEARS HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. THAT USE THE SAME KINDS
OF RESOURCES THAT HAVE MADE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR LIVES AND
SO.
AYE AYE AYE VOTE I WOULD URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY THOSE THAT
ARE LOOKING FOR.
THANK YOU AND I'M SORRY BUT
WE'RE THROUGH TAKING TESTIMONY
IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION THAT YOU OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M DAVID FISHER FROM
CASTRO VALLEY HOPE GROUP AYE
POSES BILL.
HI I'M SHOWING KRAKOWSKI FROM
VISION A CAPS MINISTRIES I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M JEANNE FISHER FROM CASTRO
VALLEY CO DIRECTOR OF HOPE GROUP
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RIVER SHARPLY REPRESENTING THE
ASSEMBLIES OF GOD NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEVADA FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MINISTERS FIVE HUNDRED
CHURCHES WE STAND OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
TAUGHT VISIT TODD PETERSON
BUSINESSMAN AND FORMER MANAGER
OF MULTIPLE COUNSELING CENTERS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BRIAN NO WELL AS A FORMER GAY
MAN I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BECKY SWEENEY INDIVIDUAL I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CRAIG SWEENY REPRESENTING
BAYSIDE CHURCH IN CITRUS HEIGHTS
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KELLY NINE HIGHS AND
MY NAME IS ERIC WATERBURY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PHILIP S. COMMUTER WILLIAM
JOSEPH UNIVERSITY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
RAY GREEN MINISTER ACTIVE
MINISTRIES WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DAMN PELLETIER. HAMILTON SQUARE
BAPTIST CHURCH RELATIVES WHO ARE
SEEKING HELP AND CANNOT GET IT.
AND A FRIEND WHO DIED BECAUSE HE
HAD SUCH TORMENT AND SOUGHT HELP
AND COULDN'T GET IT. I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
KRISTEN JOHNSON INDIVIDUAL
OPPOSE THIS BILL OF VIOLATION OF
CIVIL RIGHTS AND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
DANIEL COHEN CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
SO WHAT'S THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AGAINST THE AGENDA.
WHICH ONE DID YOU TAKE AN OATH
TO UPHOLD.
SIR.
THE BIGGEST GIVE US YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU.
JONATHAN KELLER FROM CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL WITH RESPECT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
WHEN THE SECULAR POSES SPELL IS
A VIOLATION OF LIFE LIBERTY AND
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
XENA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
IS RIGHT.
JUST WANT TO. BE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SOME CLARIFICATION.
THE BILL DOES NOT.
PROHIBIT.
COUNSELING.
WITH A PSYCHOTHERAPIST OF
SOMEBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THEIR SEXUALITY IS ARE CORRECT
THE CORRECT.
SO THEY CAN GO AND RECEIVE THEM
FROM THE THE ANALYSIS.
ACCEPTANCE SUPPORT
UNDERSTANDING.
OF FACILITATION OF.
EXPLORING THEIR SEXUALITY IS
THAT CORRECT CORRECT
AND IS THERE ANYTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT.
A PRIEST A PASTOR RABBI FROM.
SPEAKING WITH ONE OF THE
PRISONERS ONE OF THEIR MEMBERS
ABOUT ISSUES REGARDING THEIR
SEXUALITY.
NO.
THAT ONE OF THAT ONE OF THE
GENTLEMEN THAT.
SPOKE.
PART OF A GROUP CALLED NEW BORN
PERFECT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THAT IS
A VERY APPROPRIATE NAME. I LIKE
THAT.
AND.
.
THE COMMENTS MADE ALSO ABOUT THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION THEY HAVE TAKEN A
POSITION ON THIS.
AND THEY AGREE THAT.
THE CONVERSION THERAPY AND
PARENT OF THERAPY. ARE.
THERE AGAINST.
THOSE THEIR PRIEST ZACHARIAS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU SOME AREAS FOR SOME OF
THOSE CLARIFICATIONS AND AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE UP. ON
BOTH SIDESI CAME FOR THAT
REVEALED SOME VERY PERSONAL.
ASPECTS OF YOUR LIFE AND THAT'S
NEVER EASY AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE TO DO THAT.
I'M A AS A NOT SO FOLLOW UP UP
ON ON A SUMMARY RAISES.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
THIS DOES NOT STOP ANYONE FROM.
.
THE SEEKING THERAPY IN FACT
THEIR A WIDE RANGE OF REASONS
WHY YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD SEEK
THERAPY FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS I THINK THAT THAT WE TALK
ABOUT IT ALL THE TIME COUNSELING
IN SCHOOLS MAKING SURE THAT. OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE CARED FOR. AYE
AND THAT DOESN'T STOP IN
ADULTHOOD.
I THINK AN ADULT IT ALSO AND
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
THAT.
THIS IS REALLY.
IN MY ESTIMATION WHAT A CONSUMER
FRAUD ISSUE BECAUSE. I BELIEVE
THAT.
THERE'S PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR APPROPRIATE COUNTS AS PLAY
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO YOUR FAITH
BASED.
ORGANIZATION.
TO SEEK THE SUPPORT YOU NEED.
HOWEVER.
THERAPIES THAT.
START HERB OF THE HAVE THE
PROMISE.
THAT SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY IS A CHOICE.
AS PART OF THAT THERAPY.
I THINK THAT'S FOR THE FRIED LA
ASPECT COMES IN PARTICULARLY
WHEN NOT ONLY THE INDIVIDUAL.
THAT IS GOING THROUGH THAT
DIFFICULT TIME IN TRYING TO AB
BUBBA I INTEND TO COME TO THEIR
OWN IDENTITY. BUT THE FAMILIES
ARE AS WELL AND I THINK VALUES
ARE BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. UP
DURING A DIFFICULT TIME AND I
THINK THAT THE ACCESS AS STATED
IN THE REPORT THAT THIS OF. THAT
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE THERAPIES
PROVIDE ACCEPTANCE SUPPORT
UNDERSTANDING OF CLIENTS AND
WHAT HAVE YOU.
THAT ALSO PLAYS THE FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY SHOULD ALSO
BE SEEKING THE KINDS OF
THERAPIES THAT ALLOW FOR. OF THE
RELATIONSHIP TO BE A LOVING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM IN THEIR
LOVED ONE SO THAT EVERYONE GETS
A SUPPORT THEY NEED AND I THINK
THAT THIS BILL. ABSOLUTELY STILL
ALLOWS FOR THAT AND I WANNA.
THANK YOU AUTHOR FOR HIS
COURAGE.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND FOR HIS CONTINUED
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
LOVING COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU YOU DO THIS AS WELL IS
WITHOUT
BE PROHIBITED IF THE RETREAT
DEALT WITH.
ISSUES OF OF SEXUALITY.
GOOD MORNING I ANTHONY SAMPSON.
WITH ARNOLD AND PORTER SO
BECAUSE THIS.
THIS IS.
DIFFERENT THAN THAT TED LIU BILL
THAT WE SAW A SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
TWO.
WHICH WAS IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE WHICH ARE
CREATED THAT'S OUT RIGHT BAN FOR
FOR MINORS FOR PURPOSES OF OF
OF.
THE SEXUAL ORIENTATION CHANGE
EFFORTS THIS FALLS UNDER THE
CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT SO
IN THE SITUATION YOU PROVIDED
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE THAT
UNDERLYING TRANSACTION TO HAVE
OCCURRED. SO SO TO GO TO THAT
RETREAT FIRST THAT THRESHOLD
ISSUE OF AND WHAT THEIR PAYMENT
RIGHT. AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS WOULD WOULD YOU NOTE
THAT THE DEFINITION IN THE BILL
PERTAINS TO PRACTICES SO WHAT
THAT.
THAT CONFERENCE WHERE AN
INDIVIDUALS WERE SPEAKING WITH
THAT BE THERE WHAT WOULD THEY BE
PRACTICING.
I'M AND THEN OF COURSE THERE IS
THIS LINE BETWEEN WHEN YOU ENTER
INTO THIS WORLD OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION CHANGE EFFORTS WHICH
IS CLEARLY DEFINED IN THE BILL
AND WE'VE SEEN COURTS UPHELD
UPHOLD.
THAT LANGUAGE
WHEN YOU SORT OF CROSS THAT LINE
INTO CHICKEN TO SEEKING TO
CHANGE ONE'S SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
I THINK AT THAT AT CONFERENCES
WHERE WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST
SPEAKING ABOUT ABOUT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION CHANGE EFFORTS AND
THE FACT THAT THAT THAT THIS
EXISTS AND GIVE THEIR OPINIONS
ON IT AND BEING VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF IT.
THAT'S JUST THEM EXERCISING
THEIR FREE SPEECH RIGHTS IT'S
THE MOMENT THE ACROSS INTO THAT
TERRITORY AND YOU ARE SEEKING TO
CHANGE. THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
WHERE AGAIN.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SORT ACROSS
THE THRESHOLD IN THIS BILL.
BUT AGAIN THE ISSUE AGAIN WOULD
COME A YOU'D HAVE TO.
YOU KNOW ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
BEFORE YOU EVEN GET THERE WHICH
IS HAS THAT TRANSACTION
OCCURRED.
WAS THAT TRANSACTION SOLELY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ATTENDING A
CONFERENCE THAT'S
YOU KNOW SOLE FOCUS WAS ON
SEXUAL ORIENTATION CHANGE
EFFORTS.
YOU KNOW ARE THERE.
MULTIPLE SECTIONS ON MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
AND AGAIN WAS WAS WITH THAT
THEM ACTUALLY PRACTICING.
THE.
YOU KNOW THE.
BECAUSE THAT THE TERM AND THE
BILL'S PRACTICING AND SO WHETHER
THAT CONSTITUTES A PRACTICE. IN
A CONFERENCE SETTING VERSUS
PRACTICING WITHIN A CHURCH ARE
WITHIN US IN A MEDICAL FACILITY.
I THINK I'M NOT CLEAR YEAH
ACTUALLY CAUSED ME. MUCH
CONCERNED.
.
SO.
SOME CATHOLIC
WE I DON'T KNOW WHAT A TICKET
YOU WILL WE HAVE OUR OWN BASIS
RIGHT SO YOU GO ON A RETREAT
WITH THE CHURCH.
RIGHT IF YOU WANNA GET MARRIED
OR.
COUPLES RETREATS SIRS.
CHURCH THE CHURCH.
MAY BRING PEOPLE AND.
WHAT THE CHURCH UNDER THIS BILL
STOLE?
IF YOU'RE PAYING SIMPLY FOR YOUR
STATE OVERNIGHT STAY.
AND THE CHURCH HAS A PROGRAM BY
WHICH PEOPLE ARE VOLUNTARILY
ENTERING AND WANT.
WILL MAKE IT AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE.
THE CHURCH.
BRING SOMEBODY IN WHO WHO DOES
IN FACT.
SIT AROUND A CAMPFIRE IN PRE.
FOR YOUR CHANGE.
A SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
WOULD THAT BE ILLEGAL UNDER THE
SPELL.
LIKELY NOT BECAUSE IF YOU THAT
PAYMENT IS FOR THE OVERNIGHT
STAY AND THE SERVICES ARE BEING
OFFERED.
TO THE PARTICIPANTS AT NO COST
THEN.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT APPLY.
SO THAT TIED THE LEAVE BILL THAT
WE SAW WAS AGAIN JUST A POT
RIGHT PROHIBITION WHERE IS THIS
YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR THE ACT FOR
THE SERVICES BEING RENDERED.
JUST GOT APPROPRIATIONS.
RIGHT I AM.
I'M NOT SURE I FULLY UNDERSTAND
OR FEEL FULLY COMFORTABLE I I DO
THINK.
I'M I'M. COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
IDEA OR TALK ABOUT BUSINESS PARK
THIS ISN'T AND THIS IS FOR
FRAUDULENT.
I'M GETTING CONCERNED WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
REACH HER IT WOULD.
KNOWING ONCE A NORMAL BECAUSE
THAT IT COULD SPAN. A WIDE
VARIETY OF RELIGIOUS SECT.
THAT I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO
ITEM.
BUT I I I CAN'T IMAGINE WE'RE
TRYING TO. TO STEP THERE. THAT
THAT CREATES ADDITIONAL PROM SO
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORK WITH OFFER THIRDS OFFICE
JUST TO ENSURE THAT.
.
WE CAN EXPLORE ALL THE
POSSIBILITIES OF HOW THIS COULD
BE OUT.
PROHIBITING. A RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTION FROM PRACTICING
THEIR RELIGION BASICALLY WHAT
WEATHER WE BELIEVE THAT TO BE
VALID OR TRUE ARE GOOD.
WHICH I PERSONALLY DON'T.
THINK THAT.
BUT BAD.
I I THINK.
WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL THAT'S
ALSO IF IF THE AUTHOR I'M GONNA
OF COURSE SUPPORT US WITH OFF
THEIR IS WILLING SINCE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO COME TO MY COMMITTEE.
BUT WILLING TO COME TALK TO ME
THROUGH THAT THAT.
PROTECTIONS FOR UP NORMAL.
RELIGIOUS ACTED.
THE QUESTION
ON THE.
XENA MISSILE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH RESPECT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THAT THIS SPECIFICALLY IS
VERY NARROW IN SCOPE UNDER THE.
FOCUSED ON THIS TRANSACTIONS A
UNDER THE CONSUMER LEGAL
REMEDIES ACT
AND WILL STILL STAY COMMITTED
AND WILL STATE THAT IT IS NOT
THE INTENT A TO GO AFTER. OF
RELIGION OR TWO CHURCHES BUT
RATHER THIS FRAUDULENT PRACTICE
ITSELF.
ENDS OF REWRITING THAT THAT
THAT NOTION. IN THE PREVIOUS
CONVERSATION AS IT AS PASSED THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND PRIVACY
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THIS WITH SIMILAR
CONVERSATION. OF THAT SO ONE OF
OUR OTHER FELLOW COLLEAGUES WHO
WAS AN ATTORNEY.
HERSELF ALSO RAISED.
BUT THAT A SHE WAS SATISFIED
WITH THAT CONVERSATION A WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BEEN VERY NARROW
IN SCOPE ARE ON THESE
TRANSACTIONS I FINALLY JUST IT
HIT TO THE NOTION OF WHAT
THEY'D.
IF THIS CONCEPT OF CONVERSION
THERAPY.
THIS BILL IS AN LGBT CAUCUS
PRIORITY OF ALL EIGHTY LGBT
LEGISLATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS NOTION OF
CONVERSION THERAPY IN ITSELF AS
IF THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG.
THEN THERE'S SOMETHING HARDLY
WRONG.
SO ASIDE FROM FACT YES WE ARE IN
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFICS AND I
HOPEFULLY I FEEL THAT WE HAVE
ADDRESSED THOSE CONCERNS BUT
THIS NOTION OF CONVERSION
THERAPY THAT. WE'RE SOMEHOW
THERE'S SOMETHING INHERENTLY
WRONG WITH US.
IS ANTI FEDERAL CALL TO MY
EXISTENCE AND TO OUR COLLEAGUES
EXISTENCE
SIMPLY AS YOU ASK YOURSELF THAT
SAME QUESTION CAN YOU BE
CONVERTED FROM WHATEVER YOUR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION IS OR YOUR.
IDENTITY IS.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST YOU THAT THE
ANSWER IS NO AND THAT I AM
EQUALLY.
PROUD OF HOW YOU WERE BORN I AM
EQUALLY AS PROUD AS YOU STAND.
.
WE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HOPE.
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT WE ARE STATE
OF INCLUSION VERSUS EXCLUSION.
AND THAT YOU WHICH IS JUST
SIMPLY WITH LOVE
A AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. IN SUPPORTING AND
LEADING WITH FLUFF.
THANK YOU.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU. CHU AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RAYOS.
RACE I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE DO HAVE A AND ITEM WITH
SPECIAL ORDER THAT COMES UP IN
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES SO IN THE
MEANTIME.
THERE'S THAT ONE BILL ON CALL
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS AB
TWENTY TWO OH NINE BY MISTER TWO
WAY.
EXCUSE ME WE HAVE BUSINESS TO
CONDUCT SO IF YOU COULD BE.
QUIET PLEASE
THANK YOU.
CALL THE HAVE TO MEMBERS PLEASE
CUNNINGHAM.
CHIU.
CHIU NO HOLDEN.
IF YOU'VE EVER COULD YOU TAKE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OUTSIDE.
SO THAT WE MAY CONDUCT OUR
BUSINESS.
THANK YOU.
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
HOLDEN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE TWENTY
TWO OH NINE.
HOLDEN NO.
THE VOTE IS.
TO TO SEVEN AT THIS POINT SO
THAT BILL FAILS.
GO BACK THROUGH SINCE WE HAVE
FOLKS HERE.
INSIDE TO GENDER CALL ANYONE WHO
HAS NOT YET BOTH CUNNINGHAM
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
ITEM NUMBER.
TO.
WHICH IS AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN
KALRA.
CHIU.
TWO I.
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHEN
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN CUNNINGHAM AYE GARCIA
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY
NINETY GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
BOTTOM NUMBER FIVE WE TELL WITH
A ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX STONE.
CHIU.
CHIU I KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR BLOOM.
CHIU.
TO AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN REYES.
CUNNINGHAM.
CHIU.
CHU I KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
OKAY WILL TAKE ABOUT.
OKAY LET'S.
I HAVE A BILL IN PUBLIC SAFETY
ALSO THAT I'D LIKE TO TRY TO DO
SO SINCE WERE LOSING MEMBERS
LET'S TAKE A BREAK UNTIL ELEVEN
FIFTEEN.
I'LL TRY GET MY BILL DONE AND
HOPEFULLY WE GET EVERYBODY BACK
AND FINISH OUR BUSINESS TODAY
WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT
RIGHT WELCOME BACK WE ARE GOING
TO. RECONVENE THE HEARING.
AFTER OUR RECESS WE HAVE ONE
OTHER BILL TO HEAR WHICH WAS.
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS AT
ELEVEN A. M. AND THAT IS ITEM
NUMBER ONE
RIGHT COMEY CONTINUE.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THIRTY ONE
FIFTY EIGHT MISTER MATHIS.
PUTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
.
WHAT WERE SIMPLY TRYING TO DO
HERE IS INSURER THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING ACCESS THAT IF THE
FIRST PERSON GOING THROUGH THE
DOOR?
HAS AN ISSUE THAT THE PERSON
COMING IN BEHIND THEM DOES NOT.
WITH ME TODAY.
PRESENTING IS RACIAL CALL NOT
HANDED OVER HER.
LL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
MY NAME'S ROCHELLE WILL THEN I
AM OBVIOUSLY.
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY BUT I
AM ALSO EIGHT EIGHTY DEFENSE
TURNING.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MAIN CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION ABOUT AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT. THE
FIRST IS THE SPECIAL PROCEDURAL
OBSTACLES.
EIGHT ME OR THIRTY ONE FIFTY
EIGHT WHAT MERELY MIRROR OR ECHO
LAWS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ENACTED BEFORE IT SUCH AS THE
GOVERNMENT TORT CLAIMS ACT WHERE
YOU NEED. A GOVERNMENT TORT
CLAIM FILED BEFORE YOU CAN BRING
A LAWSUIT OR THE D. FE HR EEOC
WHERE YOU NEED TO ATTAIN A RIGHT
TO SUE LETTER. BEFORE YOU CAN
FILE A LAWSUIT. THIS BILL WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE DOING THE SAME
THING BUT INSTEAD OF WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
SINCE THERE'S NO AGENCY OF
ENFORCEMENT. HE WOULD BE GIVING
THAT NOTICE TO A BUSINESS OWNER
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THE SECOND POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING ITS YOUR ATTENTION IS. THE
ARGUMENT THAT HUNDREDS OF
POTENTIAL OF A MAXIMUM OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS IS
UNREASONABLE.
THAT LET ME JUST BREAKDOWN KIND
OF THE TIMELINE OF HOW THESE
CASES TRULY DO WORK AS SOMEBODY
WHO'S DEFEND IT ALMOST A HUNDRED
OF THESE LAWSUITS.
THE FIRST IS THAT IT CAN TAKE UP
TO THREE WEEKS JUST TO GET A
CAST REPORT. THAT'S JUST ENOUGH
TIME TO.
HAVE THE BUSINESS OWNER
OBTAINING CAST CONSTRUCTION GET
THE REPORT AND THEN DIGEST WHAT
THAT ACTUALLY MEANS THE SECOND
STEP IS REALLY.
IF YOU NEED TO HIRE THE
EXPERTISE OF A CONTRACTOR.
THAT CAN TAKE UP TO A MONTH JUST
AND NOT AND OF ITSELF RIGHT
THERE SU RD EATEN THE FIFTY ONE
OUT OF THE INITIAL NINETY DAYS
THAT YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN. THEN IF
YOU NEED AN ARCHITECT OR AN
ENGINEER TO REINFORCE WALLS OR
COMPLETELY MODIFY ALL OF YOUR
RESTAURANT BOOTHS OR.
COMPLETELY REDO YOUR PARKING
LOT THOSE DRAWINGS CAN TAKE
CERTAINLY UP TO A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE DAYS HAS.
IN ADDITION TO THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT IT WILL TAKE TO PULL
PERMIT.
WHICH CAN TAKE UP TO SIX MONTHS
SO THIS IS A VERY REALISTIC VERY
CONSERVATIVE.
PERIOD OF TIME TO ENGAGE IN THE
INTERACTIVE PROCESS WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR COMPLAINT IS A PERSON
WITH DISABILITY HAS BEEN HEARD.
AS WELL AS GIVING THE POWER BACK
TO THE BUSINESS OWNERS SAY HEY
HEY LET'S WORK ON THIS TOGETHER
HOW CAN I HELP YOU.
THE THIRD POINT IS WHETHER THIS
BILL WOULD INVITE FRAUD AND
STUFF AND.
THERE ARE SEVERAL LAW FIRMS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE ALREADY ABUSING THIS LAW.
THE REASON WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT TO COMBAT THE IN THIS
PROCEDURAL ASPECT IS TRULY TO
GIVE.
HOW ARE BACK TO BUSINESSES AND
THE PERSON WITH DISABILITY TO
ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION?
TO PROVIDE THAT NOTICE OF HEY
THIS IS WHAT I EXPERIENCE
HOW CAN I HOW CAN I HELP YOU
MAKE THIS BETTER FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE THAT COMES IN THE DOOR
BEHIND YOU.
AND SO WHILE OUT OF THIS
SEVENTEEN HIGHER LAWSUITS FILED
IN STATE COURT SIX IRON FORTY
THREE OF THOSE.
WERE.
.
HEARD ME OUT OF THE HUNDRED THE
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED COMPLAINTS
FILED WART SIX HUNDRED AND.
FORTY THREE OF THOSE WERE FILED
IN STATE COURT SO CLEARLY
THEY'RE STILL. OUT A VERY LARGE
AMOUNT OF COMPLAINTS BEING FILED
HERE.
THIS NUMBER IS FORTY FOURTEEN
POINT TWO PERCENT HIGHER THAN IT
WAS LAST YEAR WHICH IS I IN MY
OPINION PRETTY ALARMING AND
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT OF THOSE
LAWSUITS. OUT WERE FILED BY FOR
LAW FIRMS.
ABUSES ARE YOU TAKING PLACE.
THE FOURTH POINT I'D LIKE TO
BRING UP IS THAT.
THAT THE ARGUMENT THAT
IGNORANCE IS NOT A DEFENSE I'D
LIKE TO POSE THIS QUESTION TO
EACH MEMBER HERE.
HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE A CPA TO
HELP YOU WITH THE TAX CODE?
YOU HAVE HELP FOR THAT.
THE TAX CUT HAS BEEN ENACTED
MUCH LONGERTHAN THE AMERICAN
WITH DISABILITIES ACT AND YET.
BUSINESSES ARE BEING FORCED TO
KNOW EVERY SINGLE LAW IN THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
CONSTRUCTION WISE AND THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODES
WITHOUT ANY HELP.
THIS BILL GIVES THAT POWER BACK
TO THE BUSINESS OF SAY HOW CAN I
HELP YOU HOW CAN WORK TOGETHER
AS A TEAM TO PROACTIVELY MAKE
SURE THE BUSINESSES BECOME
COMPLIANT WITH THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT AND THE
CALIFORNIA ON IRAQ'S.
SO THIS BILL STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE SUCH AS
PERSONS.
BETWEEN OF MYSELF WHO ARE
DISABLED PERSONS WHO NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ENJOY ACCESS TO
BUSINESSES.
BUT THE FLIP SIDE OF IT IS IS
ALSO STRIKE THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE FOR THE BUSINESS TO
INVEST BACK INTO THEIR BUSINESS
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE
LITIGATION. EXPENSE OF ATTORNEYS
FEES.
AND PARDON ME AND SETTLEMENT
WHICH WILL INCREASE WHICH WILL
OFFER YOU INCLUDE LITIGATION AND
ATTORNEYS FEES SORT SURELY IS
THE MOST ECONOMICAL WAY THAT THE
PROBLEM CAN BE SOLVED BETWEEN
THE TWO PARTIES.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
HAVE ON OUR HOUSING WITH THE
CIVIL RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M WE
ARE CROSS DISABILITY
ORGANIZATION I JUST I'M I WANT
TO MAKE A FEW POINTS TO ADDRESS
THE COMMENT THAT THE WITNESS
MADE. NUMBER ONE OF BUSINESS IS
ONE OF THE PROACTIVE MICHIGAN A
CAST INSPECTION PRIOR TO BEING
SUIT. THAT'S THE OF THE FIRST
MECHANISM TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
SECOND OF ALL AND THIS IS NOT
THE SAME AS OTHER AREAS OF LOT
NO OTHER PROTECTED CLASS HAS TO
GO THROUGH PROCEDURAL HERDERS
HURDLES TO ADDRESS THEIR RIGHTS.
NO ONE WOULD SAY TO A PERSON WHO
IS AFRICAN AMERICAN OR WOMAN
THAT YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THESE HURDLES BEFORE YOU CAN
ASSERT WHAT YOUR RIGHTS ARE. SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I
ADDRESS THOSE PIECES LITIGATION
IS THE ONLY WAY THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES CAN
ENFORCE OUR RIGHTS THERE ARE NO
PRIVATE INSPECTORS THAT GO
AROUND OTHER THAN A CAST. IF A
BUSINESS IS PROACTIVE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR.
ENVIRONMENT IS ACCEPTABLE
PARTY'S
SO I I YOU KNOW I EXTRA LITTLE
BIT WITH THE COMMENTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE BEING MADE IF
BUSINESSES WANT TO BE PROACTIVE
THEY SHOULD DO THAT BEFORE THE
BEEN SUED THE STUBBLE RIGHTS
LAWS HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS. FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND AND THEY
SHOULD MAKE THEMSELVES AWARE OF
THOSE THEY SHOULD HIRE ATTORNEYS
AT THE CONFUSED THIS IS PART OF
DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND. IN THE NATION IF
YOUR INCOME ENGAGE IN BUSINESS
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
LOOK AT THOSE ASPECTS OF OF
BUSINESS ON.
ACTIVITIES SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE WE ADDRESS THOSE.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL CIVIL
RIGHTS LAW FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF REFORM THROUGH THE LAST FEW
YEARS THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT
MORE TIME IS NEEDED.
IF WE LOOK BACK AT THE ROTH
BILL WHICH WHILE WE OPPOSED DID
THEM INSTALL.
UP TO HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS TO
ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES ARE AMONG THE CAST
INSPECTION WAS DONE IN ADVANCE.
THERE'S NO NEED FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL REFORM AND AND WITH
THOSE COMMENTS I'M GOING TO
CLOSE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE BUT
AS I SAID THERE'S A BILL A LOT
OF REFORM ON THE BOOKS. THERE'S
NO INDICATION THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL REFORM AND MANY OF
THESE ACCESS ISSUES ARE VERY
EASY TO FIX THEY'RE NOT
COMPLICATED THERE'S THIS THERE
ARE SIMPLE AS FOR EXAMPLE. YOU
KNOW BUT IF YOU BLOCK YOUR
ACCESSIBLE STALL WITH TOILET
PAPER UNIQUE TO MOVE THAT YOU
DON'T USE YOUR ACCESSIBLE STALL
FOR STORAGE YOU DON'T BLOCK THE
ACCESSIBLE BATHROOM WITH FOR
EXAMPLE HIGH CHAIRS SO THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES CAN'T
ACCESS THOSE. THOSE AREAS SO
VERY BASIC FIXES AND IN MANY OF
THESE CASES NOT ALL OF THEM BUT
AS I SAID IN IN A LOT OF
INSTANCES THE LAWS HAVE BEEN
CHANGED TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
SO I I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE WITNESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RUTHIE
GOLD CORN I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS WHO SPEAKS ON BEHALF OF
SEVENTEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITIES. ONCE AGAIN WE
ARE MAKING EFFORTS TO COME TO
YOU TOO AGAIN VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE
YET ANOTHER ATTEMPT.
TO PUNISH THE SEVENTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO DISABILITIES BY
INFRINGING UPON OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
PUTTING MORE BARRIERS IN OUR
PATH. TO BUSINESSES BECAUSE THE
BILLS WHICH HAVE IN EVERYTHING
IN COMMON WITH THE PREVIOUS ONES
BUSINESSES ARE GIVEN A PASS TO
COMPLIANCE.
SIXTEEN NO WAY ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX
TO SIXTY NINE WENT AS FAR AS WE
WILL ALLOW AS IS YOU WILL ALLOW.
TO INFRINGE ON OUR RIGHT TO FREE
AND EQUAL ACCESS TO BE CONSUMERS
SPEND OUR MONEY AND SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS A SOLUTION LOOKING FOR A
PROBLEM THE PROBLEM THAT WAS
ADDRESSED WITH SOLUTIONS THAT WE
ALLOWED BECAUSE LAW. AS AS AS
WRITTEN AND THE BILLS THAT
PREVIOUSLY CAME FORWARD WE WERE
FORCED TO CAPE.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
WE DO NOT HAVE A PROBLEM.
AND WE THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY
ARE NOT THE PROBLEM.
BUSINESSES HAVE A PROBLEM.
IF YOU DO NOT INTUITIVELY
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE AN ACCESSIBLE PARKING
SPACE.
AND A PATH OF TRAVEL INTO YOUR
BUSINESS YOU ARE IN VIOLATION OF
THE LAW HOW CAN YOU NOT KNOW
THAT.
HOW BECAUSE AS A SMALL BUSINESS?
I JUST OPENED IN A STRIP MALL.
IT'S NOT MY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THAT PARKING LOT TO BE
COMPLIANT.
IT IS THE PROPERTY OWNER BUT I'M
THE ONE IT'S GOING TO BEAR THAT
RESPONSIBLY BECAUSE THE LAW IT
READS THAT WAY.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD
TO GET OUT LAWS IN PLACE AND
BILLS WRITTEN THAT THE ROAD THE
RESPONSIBILITY WHERE IT BELONGS.
ON MUNICIPALITIES.
BUILDING OFFICIALS INFORMATION
ON CAST PROGRAMS AND
AVAILABILITIES AND NOT LETTING.
COLDWELL BANKER AND THEY'RE LIKE
OFF THE HOOK FOR THEIR
COMMERCIAL SHOPPING CENTERS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT SOLVE A
PROBLEM.
A PROBLEM HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE AT
BEEN ADDRESSED IN SIXTEEN OH
EIGHT.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX.
AND TO SIXTY NINE AND WE ARE
DONE BEING TOLD THAT IT IS OUR
JOB TO TELL YOU WHAT YOUR
PROBLEM IS.
HIRE AN EXPERT.
OR HIGHER ONE OF US AND WILL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TELL YOU WE
DO NOT VOLUNTEER.
WE WANT TO GIVE YOU ARE MONEY
YOU WHAT THE DEAD PRESIDENTS IN
MY WALLET.
I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO GIVE IT
TO YOU LET MY PEOPLE IN. THANK
YOU
.
MY NAME IS JEFF TARGET HERE.
I'M AN ADVOCATE.
I'M I AM HERE BECAUSE IS I'VE
DIRECTED LAST YEAR TO.
MR OUTLIERS
THAT IT IS THE BILL DE IN
OWNERS.
THEY HAVE NOT FOR TWENTY YEARS
CORRECTED.
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR BUILDINGS.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY LIKE
IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY WE ARE
WORKING AT SEEING THAT A BETTER
CHECK LIST GETS THERE SO THAT
THE.
BILL DO YOU KNOW OUR AND
BUSINESS OWNERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO I'VE ASSUMING
YOU ARE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE.
EXPRESSION OF CASH MEANS
EVADED SPECTER THAT KNOWS AND
UNDERSTANDS THE DISABILITY LAWS.
AYE ECHOED THE THINGS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE. I AM HERE
IN VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING AS YOU MAY SEE I AM
WEARING CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
RETIRED AMERICANS.
WE HAVE AN ISSUE THAT THE
SUPREME TO LEAVE THAT SOLE
RIGHTS AND PROTECTED. AND THAT
THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT MORE MORE SENIORS ARE ALSO
HAVING TO.
DEAL WITH OF ACCESSIBILITY.
I ALSO DOOR WITH A SLAM A DOG
FIGHTER SO YOU DOGGEDLY SEE ME
COMING IN HERE AND SAYING TO YOU
GUYS YOU NEED TO DO BETTER LOS.
AND IT'S PLEASE THINK ABOUT THIS
I KNOW THERE IS AN ISSUE BUT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN FAR BETTER
AT DEALING WITH FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS.
BEEN PRETTY MUCH ANY OTHER STATE
SO PLEASE TAKE THE LEAD.
DON'T GET CAUGHT UP WITH
SAYING THAT.
BECAUSE THIS IS OCCURRING
THIS IS A WAY BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THIS IS GOING TO PROVIDE
ANY BETTER SOLUTION.
RIGHT NOW
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS KEVIN BACK AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA POSED FOR THE REASONS
STATED IN THE COMMITTEES TEXANS
ANALYSIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SITTING ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CAN LOOK IF YOU.
A FUNNY ARNOLD THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME TESTIFY I HAVE THESE
LETTERS I'M TURNING INTO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THIS BILL IS JUST
ANOTHER A ENTANGLEMENT OF OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO
EXERCISE AND HAVE ACCESS TO
BUILDINGS.
AND ALL OF THIS IS ALREADY
OCCURRED TO MAKE THINGS EASIER
AND MORE ACCEPTABLE TO
BUSINESSES.
GENERALLY SPEAKING A IN IN MANY
ATTORNEYS JUST WRITE THE LETTER
AND SEE IF YOU CAN SETTLE
OUTSIDE. OF COURT BUT A LOT OF
THE BUSINESSES DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
AND.
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE LACK
OF ACCESSIBILITY. I HAVE A
FRIEND WHO'S A SENIOR WHO JUST
BECAME DISABLED WHO HAS A
COLOSTOMY BAG NOW.
BECAUSE SHE ALMOST DIED.
SHE'S IN A NURSING HOME.
IN THE COMMUNITY I LIVE IN I
LIVE IN ELK GROVE.
AND IT'S A REHAB FACILITY.
NOT ONE ACCESSIBLE.
FACILITY BATHROOM IN THAT WHOLE
PLACE.
NOT ONE WHAT YEAR IS THIS.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THESE LAWS WERE PUT ON THE
BOOKS.
THE AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES
ACT.
WAS PUT ON THE BOOKS IN NINETEEN
NINETY ENTITLED TWENTY FOUR WAS
PUT ON THE BOOKS.
I BELIEVE IT WAS JUNE OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE.
SO THESE BUSINESSES COME BACK
EVERY YEAR JUST GREEN THAT THEY
NEED HELP THAT WERE SO TERRIBLE
THE DISABLED PEOPLE. WHY IS THIS
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
REMOVING THEIR BARRIERS?
THEY KNOW THAT YOU ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE STANDING IN A COURT OF
LAW. TO ADDRESS THE BARRIERS
MANY PEOPLE DON'T EVEN ASSERT
THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS TO REMOVE THE
BARRIERS.
AND.
.
THIS BILL IS JUST ANOTHER HURDLE
TO TELL PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THEY MUST SEND A CERTIFIED
LETTER. AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
BY A BUSINESS WHO HAS NOT
REMOVE THEIR BARRIERS.
AND.
.
YOU IT REQUIRES A CERTAIN LEVEL
EXPERTISE IT REQUIRES KNOWLEDGE.
AND ACCESS CODES AND WHAT IS
REQUIRED IT REQUIRES THAT A
PERSON BE A EDUCATED.
AND.
IT AND IT COST MANY PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF INCOME MONEY
TO TELL THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
NOT ACCESSIBLE.
AND.
GIVES THEM TIME TO REMOVE
BARRIERS WHICH ARE WAY PAST
OVERDUE IN BEING REMOVED.
SO IT'S ANOTHER OBSCENE BILL AND
JUST DID TO LET YOU KNOW. THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. AND I I WANT TO TELL YOU
WHY THEY'RE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY HAVE
ACCESS BARRIERS. CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT OIL MARKETERS
ASSOCIATION AND CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW LET ME TELL YOU WHO OPPOSES
THIS BILL.
A ACLU OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS
FOR DISABILITY RIGHTS.
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA ONE
INDIVIDUAL AND I GUESS THAT
WOULD BE TOO BECAUSE I JUST
TURNED IN MY LETTER TODAY.
CONNIE ALL LONG TERM DISABILITY
RIGHTS ADVOCATE THIRTY YEARS
ADVOCATING FOR ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES NOT ONLY
BEFORE COMMITTEES SUCH AS THIS
BUT BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
AND TESTIFYING WHAT ACCESS CODES
ARE NEEDED AND EVERYTHING IS
GETTING HARDER AND HARDER FOR
PEOPLE IT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I LEARN
SOMETHING NEW. FROM MY FRIEND
WHO NOW HAS A COLOSTOMY BAG.
BECAUSE
A.
THERE ARE KNOW TOILET FACILITIES
REALLY FOR PEOPLE WITH COLOSTOMY
BAGS.
SO ALTHOUGH WE ADVOCATED AND
SOME YOUNG ADVOCATES PASSED THE
ADULT CHANGING TABLES
FACILITIES.
A BILL AND UNDER BONY OF.
A YEAR TO GO.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON GETTING
ACTUAL CODES FOR AMUSEMENT PARKS
AND LARGER VENUES.
IF YOU END UP WITH A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE A COLOSTOMY BAG.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
TO DEAL WITH THAT THEY HAVE TO
EMPTY.
AND.
MS ANOTHER AREA THAT YOU LIVE
UP PLEASE THAT NEEDS ADVOCACY.
SO I AM DEFINITELY FOR ALL THE.
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS REASONS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IN ASKING
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND
DON'T BRING ANY MORE THESE
OBSCENE BILLS BACK. THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE SOME MORE PEOPLE.
SPEAK WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
SUBSTANTIVE ALREADY IF WE COULD
BE BRIEFLY. YEAH MY NAME IS
JOSEPH VERY HOME THAT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT OF THIS REALLY
ORGANIZED GROUP FOR INITIATED
TOTALLY QUALITY. OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS DOGFIGHT.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
CINDY THREAT TO THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WE SUPPORT WHAT OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA HAS STATED NO
OTHER CLASS IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE NOTICE BEFORE THEY SEE
YOU UNDER THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND PEOPLE DISABILITY SHOULD
ALSO NOT BE ABLE TO BE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS TARA CHERRY.
I WAS ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF THE PHYSICALLY
HANDICAPPED.
AND WE WERE THE ONES WHO PASSED
THE ORIGINAL BILLS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE RIVER CUTTING EDGE.
AND THOSE BILLS.
WENT ON TO BECOME THE BASIS
FOR THE AMERICAN DISABILITIES
ACT SO I WOULD AT THIS A LONG
TIME I'M EIGHTY THREE.
AND I'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS.
WE DREAMED OF AND ACCESSIBLE
SOCIETY BECAUSE MANY OF US WERE
DENIED. EMPLOYMENT.
WE WERE DENIED SCHOOL.
WERE DENIED ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
AND WE WORK TO BECOME CITIZENS.
THE.
BUT THERE WOULD FINALLY
RECOGNIZED THAT WE WERE PEOPLE I
WAS AMAZING.
AND I GOT RIGHT.
I GOTTA WRITE TEN EDUCATION I
GOTTA RIGHT TO TRANSPORTATION I
GOTTA WRITE.
LIVE AS A HUMAN BEING AND AS A
CITIZEN.
IN ADDITION TO MY WHEELCHAIR I
AM NOW ALMOST TOTALLY DEAF.
WHICH AT MAKES LIFE EVEN MORE
INTERESTING.
I'M I WISH THAT YOU IN THIS
CHAMBER AND HAD SOME CAPTIONING
AND YOU DON'T. AND MOST OF THE
HEARING ROOMS DON'T THE BIGGER
ASSEMBLY ROOM SOME.
THEY HAVE.
SOME CLOSE CAPTIONING AND THEY
HAVE SOME REAL TIME CAPTIONING.
WE'VE DREAMED OF AN EGG SAYS
WELL SOCIETY WHICH IS NOT ALL
THAT DIFFERENT CALLED.
RETRO FIT THIS EXPENSIVE.
DESIGNING A BUILDING THAT OF
SUCCESS SIMPLE TO BEGIN WITH IS
AB. BREGENZ HAD WONDERFUL IDEA
AND I WISH THE ALLEY DE PEOPLE.
I'M SORRY THAT'S L. E. D. PEOPLE
WERE DOING THAT AS A MATTER OF
COURSE.
I NEED TO POINT OUT SOMETHING
THAT I SINCE I'M DEAF I DIDN'T
HEAR A LOT OF WHAT WAS SAID BUT
I DIDN'T SEE ANYBODY SLIPS.
MENTIONING EMPLOYMENT.
X..
THAT'S ABILITY IS GREAT IF YOU
MADE THE GOODS AND SERVICES OF A
BUSINESS.
IF YOU NEED EMPLOYMENT YOU NEED
ACCESS AND THAT'S IS VERY SELDOM
EVER MENTION WHERE THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT ACCESS.
ACCESS IS ALL THE CIVIL RIGHTS
HAVE ONE OF THOSE IS THE RIGHT
TO GET A JOB.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN KEEP IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SURE CAN GET IT.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS KIND OF A BILL DOESN'T
SHOW UP AGAIN.
THAT WE PASSED A LAW AND MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS FOR TO YEARS
THEIR BEEN LAWS FOR
ACCESSIBILITY. AND I'M.
BUSINESS OWNERS SHARE SAW SAYING
OH GEE I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THAT
THAT'S A LIE.
AND IT'S A SERIOUS LIE AND IT'S
IMPEDING THE LIVES OF MANY MANY
PEOPLE.
OUR MEDICAL CARE IS SO MUCH
BETTER.
WHEN I HAD POLIO IN NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE WHICH IS BEFORE ANY
IF YOU WERE BORN.
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE.
HELP.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT DISEASE
ANYMORE WE DON'T HAVE POLIO
ANYMORE WE STILL GOT WHEELCHAIRS
AND WE STILL NEED ACCESS. THIS
BILL IS.
STUPID THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THING THAT I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
HERE WHERE GOD I'M A A OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL I THINK THIS GOES
MUCH FURTHER THAN WE'VE EVEN
TALKED ABOUT. THE LAST TIME THAT
YOU HAVE BROUGHT A BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE WORK PRETTY HARD TO
CREATE A FRAMEWORK I. HAVE HEARD
THE CONCERNS ABOUT A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF LAW FIRMS.
THAT HAVE BEEN FILING THE SUITS
BUT WE TRY TO BUILD SOME PROCESS
AROUND THAT AND.
AND GO AFTER THE.
DOES
HI.
PROFILE FILERS BUT YET THE FACT
REMAINS THAT.
IT'S IT IT'S AGAINST THE LAW TO
HAVE A FACILITY WITHOUT ACCESS.
AND TO TURN THE TABLES WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO ON THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IS IS.
JUST UNFAIR AND AND FURTHERING
AND UNFAIRNESS IN IN IN EQUITY
FOR THEM.
SO I I JUST CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SO MISSOURI.
MISTER KILEY.
THANK YOU PROMISED HER.
.
BUT IT JUST AS A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I DO WANT TO
THANK RUTHIE FROM FOR COMING
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE.
TO COME AND TESTIFY GREAT
ADVOCATE FOR THE INLAND EMPIRE
SUPPORT.
.
COMMITTEE OF.
DISABLED PERSONS AND I THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I THINK THAT.
.
THE COMMENTS HAVE ALL BEEN MADE
BUT I JUST WANTED TO. INCLUDE
THAT IN A RECORD TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
I THINK YOU ANSWERED YOUR AYE I
DO HAVE A DIFFERENT TAKE ON ON
THIS BILL.
AND I DO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES WHO CAME HERE TO
TESTIFY BUT I. I'M NOT SURE IT'S
HELPFUL TO CALL BILL STUPID AND
OBSCENE I WENT BACK I THINK THIS
IS REALLY A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE.
AND I'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE HOW
WE'VE HAD BIPARTISAN ATTEMPTS
FOR MR GRAY AND MR MATHIS BEFORE
TO TRY TO GET WHAT EVELYN REALLY
RECOGNIZES THE PROBLEM. AND I
SEE THIS IS PUTTING ON THE ONE
HAND.
MILLIONS OF BUSINESS OWNERS AND
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS IN THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY AGAINST ON
THE OTHER HAND THOSE WHO PROFIT
FROM THIS PREDATORY LUNATIC
LITIGATION. AND THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S TRUE THAT I CALIFORNIA THE
DISABILITIES HAVE NOT ALWAYS
GOTTEN THE PRIORITY THAT THEY
SHOULD FROM THIS LEGISLATURE.
BUT MR MATHIS HAS BEEN I THINK
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHAMPIONS ARE
ON THIS AND. I SEVERAL OTHER
MEASURES FOR CALIFORNIA'S WITH
DISABILITIES SO I I THINK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS ABOUT THIS AND
I I URGE YOU TO CONTINUE THE
FIGHT.
IF YOU OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SINGH NANDA SIR MATHIS YOU
MIKLOS.
MEMBERSHIP IN IN THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE I I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR.
THE AND I WANT TO SHARE THE
STORY ABOUT MY SON.
.
HE WAS BORN WITH SPINA BIFIDA.
OR ACTUALLY FACING ANOTHER
SURGERY FOR HIM IN THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS.
WIT WHICH HE MAY END UP
PERMANENTLY IN A WHEELCHAIR.
.
SO QUITE FRANKLY THE IDEA THAT
IT WOULD BE TURNING THE TABLES
ON MY OWN CHILD.
.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
MY FAMILY IS PART OF THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY WE ARE PART
OF THE SEVENTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
I WORK WITH THE FAMILIES AT
HOME.
WE TALK TO THEM WE HEAR THESE
ISSUES.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU ALL TODAY.
IT'S SIMPLY ENSURING.
THAT WE ARE BREAKING THE
BARRIERS
THAT WHEN ACCESS IS.
BLOCK IS DENIED.
THAT WE'D FIX IT.
SO THAT THE NEXT PERSON COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR.
DOES IT HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
TRAGIC EVENT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
ALL EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
WORKING TOGETHER.
I'M NOT TRYING TO DENY ACCESS TO
ANYBODY ON TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
ACCESS IS THERE.
FOR THE NEXT PERSON IN LINE THAT
WE ARE PAYING IT FORWARD.
FOR EVERYBODY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT WE ARE ENSURING.
THAT THINGS GET FIX.
FOR ME THIS ISN'T ABOUT LAWSUITS
TO SUSAN ABOUT ANY OF THIS THIS
IS ABOUT THE SIMPLE FACT.
THAT WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM THERE'S FORTY
YEARS PLUS OF CASE LAW WILL
MEMBERS I'M ONLY THIRTY FIVE.
WE HAVE IMMIGRANTS TO OUR
COUNTRY WHO ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO BARELY UNDERSTAND
ENGLISH LET ALONE THE
COMPLICATIONS OF OUR LAW.
WE HAVE YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS WHO
DON'T REALIZE ALL THESE THINGS
WE HAVE CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES THAT GIVE THESE
PEOPLE PERMITS THE SAKE HAGER
GOOD TO GO SO THEY'RE EXCITED
AND THEY THINK THEY'RE OKAY.
THE FACT IS WE HAVE A BROKEN
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS DENYING
ACCESS
FOR OUR DISABLED COMMUNITY.
AND THAT NEEDS TO GET FIXED.
IN THIS BILL BEFORE YOU INSURERS
THAT. AS THESE THINGS ARISE
WE CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND GET.
THE BARRIERS BROKEN DOWN AND GET
THEM FIXED AN ENSURE IT'S NOT
JUST A LITIGATION. IT'S NOT A
LOSS TO IT'S KEEPING THE DOORS
OPEN AND PROVIDING ACCESS FOR
EVERYBODY.
I ENCOURAGE YOUR I'VE THOUGH AND
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BECAUSE I WANT TO ENSURE THAT MY
SON.
WHO WAS BORN WITH A DISABILITY
HAS A BRIGHTER FUTURE AND THE
BARRIERS ARE BROKEN DOWN FOR AN
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IS OUR
SECOND.
AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU COLOR ROBOTICS STONE
NO STONE NO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
CHU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT FLETCHER NO HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RAYOS.
REYES NO.
THE BILL IS THREE THREE SO I
WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU IF WE COULD GET OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BACKS
WE COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS. THAT
IS THERE IS ONE BILL ON CALL AND
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON.
THEY DO THAT.
OKAY IF YOU COULD OPEN A ROLE ON
CONSENT CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I..
GOT A BUNCH.
YEAH
SO WILL GO THROUGH AND.
ABOUT ADD ONS.
AND YOU GET THE POINT.
SO ITEM TO WHICH IS AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
THREE SUMS ARE TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN CUNNINGHAM AYE GARCIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWO OH NINE
OH GONZALEZ FLETCHER CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS AB
TWENTY TWO OH NINE CHOI.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I.
I DON'T EVER SIX AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX STONE. KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FOUR BLOOM.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
AND THAT WAS ON AB TWENTY THREE
SEVEN SIX.
OKAY.
I'M NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FOUR BLOOM.
KILEY.
NOT VOTING.
AB I'VE NEVER ATE AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ARRESTS.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY THREE LOW.
CUNNINGHAM.
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
THANK YOU QUICKLY GET OTHER
MEMBERS HERE.
WE WOULD APPRECIATE IF WE COULD
WRAP UP OUR BUSINESS
THERE IS ONE BILL ON CALL
I AM GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. THIRTY ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. MATHIS THE VOTE IS
THREE THREE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO SHALL.
CHAO NO.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA THANK YOU I'M
GONNA.
LEAVE THAT CALL OPEN FOR NOW IS
MEMBERS COME IN
THAT CALL IS OPEN ON A. B..
THIRTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE THE VOTE IS.
THREE TO FOUR THREE AYE FOR
KNOWS CALL THE CHAIR VOTING. NO.
CHIU HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA NO.
WHY WOULD
OKAY SO ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B.
THIRTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT THEIR
CURRENT VOTES STANDS AT THREE TO
FIVE SO THAT BILL DOES FAIL?
IS IT WOULD HAVE NEEDED SIX
VOTES IN ORDER TO PASS.
AND WITH THAT I KNOW THAT THE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAD NOT VOTER
GOING TO REGISTER NOT VOTING.
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH